Where' this thing go? View
docs. There it is.
Perfect. So, I've been gone a while. Um,
I'll wait till a few people are here
before I tell that story, but I took a
vacation.
I am back
and I still have some other stuff I'm
going to be working on off stream here
and there. Um, but I'm in Florida now
and the goal is going to be to just
crank out the rest of Puffer 40.
There are quite a few things in order to
do that. Um,
merry Christmas to you as well. Uh,
there are quite a few things left for
the 40 release. The main one is taming
the low-level mess uh with torch and
figuring out how I'm going to structure
everything, getting everything
numerically stable and hitting our 10
mil performance number. Once we get
that, it's just a ton of experiments and
some tweaks to constellation.
for the most part. Uh let me show you
guys a little bit. I because I did do a
few things off uh off stream over the
last several days. So let me just go
ahead and show you that. Um this is from
yesterday. I've been experimenting with
torch compile on chunks of C++ instead
of on chunks of Python. But the main
main thing that I did uh while I was
away
We now have a working C uh C not C++
threading uh vectorization
implementation.
And this thing also does GPU buffering.
So this is dramatically dramatically
faster in almost all cases uh than what
we had before with Puffer. And what we
had before with Puffer was already
state-of-the-art. So, this is going to
be a nice performance boost for pretty
much everything,
including some stuff for our clients and
including some stuff for um partnered
labs. So,
I'm very excited to get this out there.
It's going to still take a little bit
more work and we have some other things
to do before I can finish this up. But
what we're going to do on stream today,
my plan for today is to attempt to tame
torch compile. Let me show you what I
mean by that.
So
the thing that I realized is uh CUDA
launch overhead is a problem.
That doesn't go away in C++. You just
get rid of the Python overhead.
And there are two ways to get rid of two
realistic ways we can get rid of CUDA
overhead.
One is with CUDA graphs
um which is not through PyTorch though
there are a couple hooks into it and the
other is with torch compile.
Now, I'm a little bit conflicted on this
because
if I add the CUDA support directly to
native C++,
you know, I'm kind of doing something
outside of what Torch does. I don't
really get all the same things that
Torch compile gets. um it will kill the
launch overhead but it's then pretty
difficult for me to take chunks of the
C++ or the C yeah C++ for torch the C++
torch code and bind it to Python because
I'm going to want to bind chunks in
between uh CUDA bounds also just adds a
whole bunch of code uh now I could use
torch compile right over chunks of the
code but the problem with torch compile
now is um for whatever whatever reason,
and this drives me insane. I really,
really do not like the way Torch
compiles implemented. It's entirely
written on the Python side, and it's
done so in a way where you cannot easily
go to the C++ bounds, even though that's
exactly what you'd want to do. So, I
have to expose certain things to Python
in ways that change how I have to write
the C++ a little bit. Um, but I think
this is worth experimenting with because
my hope and the reason that I think that
this is now worth doing is because I
have most of the network in C++. I think
that the compile time overhead should be
very small compared to what it used to
be and I think you're still going to get
quite good performance without it. So,
we're going to try that. And the problem
is even if I do cudigraphs, cudigraphs
is also going to introduce launch
overhead because it's the same sort of
tracing operation.
Audio only working on Twitch. I don't
remotely know how that's possible.
Seriously,
hang on, let me check.
test. Is this working?
Hello.
Huh? Test. Is this working? Uh, one
moment. Hello.
>> Audio is working on X perfect. Wait.
Well, I can't hear myself.
>> Working. Uh, one moment.
>> Hello.
>> I can hear you down on YouTube.
All right. Thank you for the false
positive report, my friend.
Great.
I'm not starting off the uh news stream
with completely messing up my setup.
All right, where were we? So, the um the
thing that we're going to do with torch
compile, right? Uh, we're going to see
if the overhead is not as bad when you
have big chunks of your net in C++.
I think it should be fine if we do it
this way.
Have I gained weight? I've gained
Well, not actually since I left. Uh
since the summer I've gained about four
or five pounds back on mostly muscle,
but I lost um
before the summer I lost 18 lbs or like
over the summer 6 weeks
on a big cut. And now I'm actually I
will probably end up putting some fat
back on because I'm trying to get back
into some heavier training. Started
squatting again and whatnot.
Um, okay.
Yeah. So, I guess the thing that is
still to be seen, which is that I could
do this all day today and it could still
not work, is torch compile could still
be a mess even with big chunks of the
network in C uh C++.
But
the only other option is to do
everything manually with CUDAs.
And the thing that really puts me off of
that is you don't get kernel search if
you do it that way. So you don't even
have the option to try like um max
autotune for better kernels or anything
like that.
So I'm going to try this. The goal for
today is like really clean
implementation with torch compile uh and
C++ networks and we're going to see how
things work from there.
Okay. So to start this off,
I believe
we're trying to compile uh the forward
pass of the policy here
and I believe that the difficulty here
was Right. Right. Right. So there's I
actually went and grabbed Claude for
this. Um because there's literally not
even to like write code, but because
there are no docs anywhere. Like there
literally are no docs for this. Um so
we're going to see if this is made up
[ __ ] Uh Grock just gave me madeup
[ __ ] that didn't work. Wasn't even
part of the API. So this essentially
says because there is no documentation
in torch for what I'm supposed to do
with um like full network for passes
according to this though
I
what is it?
Oh actually it did make up some [ __ ]
and then I gave it the uh the LSTM
source. Okay. Yes, that's what it was.
So
apparently you can bind
ops like this
Apparently this works.
We will see.
I'm put this over on my other monitor.
And
this is what we're going to try. So,
first thing
I think this is one of the things that I
really needed to take a vacation from as
well. Like this whole API, their whole
the way they do all their C++ is so
fiddly. It's very difficult to make any
progress quickly. And it's really not um
it's sort of a C++ problem, but it's not
like a low-level dev problem. It's just
like a engineering own goal.
It's just really not designed very well.
Okay. So here we can define this should
be.
And then this needs to also get
uh we need a definition for the
but I think that this is the same. So
here let me explain something. So this
thing here
this is the meta kernel. This is
actually not recommended by the torch
authors themselves. They actually have
several points where they recommend that
you do this.
This instead policy port abstract
you do something like this.
But then this one is bound to the wrong
op, right?
Yeah, because this is this is the wrong
op. So this needs to go to
policy forward.
That seems weird to me as well though.
Hang on. Is there um
So, this is what I'm trying to figure
out, folks. Um,
so in Torch,
they obviously have um C++
classes that they have exposed to Python
that work with Torch Compile. Their
guides do not tell you how to do this
one bit. So this is completely
undocumented and it's a complete mess
which is a bad combination.
But what I think is going to happen is
if we look here there's actually they're
not managing the weights here. You can
see that there are not any weights
declared.
This is state not weights.
So
where is it?
Test C API. I don't want it to test.
Okay, here it is. Yeah, this one. So
here is their RNN in C++.
Okay. CL params.
CL params.
I have so much code devoted to
quantization for this.
Cell type
I'm looking for.
Okay. LSTM imple.
What is this? Is this the hoorde
function?
Okay, so here we see that they actually
they do have a version of this function,
right, that takes all the parameters. So
this is not just tied to a class.
Oh, do they even have a class in here?
Wait, maybe they don't have a class.
Well, something has to manage the uh
something has to be managing these
parameters though, right?
Okay, this is actually youthful here.
So,
This bothers me like quite a bit that uh
it is this way. But I think I should I
think it is worth trying to figure this
out. Um
just so we can compare and use torch
compile directly cuz like if I do
cudraph manually, right?
Honestly kind of tempted.
It's probably doing the same thing under
the hood, isn't it?
Hang on. Let me think about this clearly
because
the only graphs which do not mutate
inputs.
Okay,
How's progress on Puffer 4? Welcome. So,
I have a prototype that works and is
fast for vectorization.
And now we're basically trying to figure
out the CUDA launch overhead. Uh, I got
up to 6.5,
I believe, 6.5 million steps per second
and the target is 10. Good chunk of its
CUDA overhead. So, that's what we're
looking at right now.
>> Okay. So options. Let me just make sure
I think through this because it seems
like either way I do this, it's going to
be a total pain and I want to make sure
I'm doing it sely. So
options are
use torch compile or do cudographs
manually.
Um
torch compile will do cudigraphs for
you.
It also has a slower to compile mode uh
that can potentially produce faster
kernels.
The annoyance with this is that torch
compile is terribly designed. It's very
often slower
from what I've seen and there's very
little uh ability to figure out why.
I can technically torch compile
different chunks of the code the same
way I can do photographs into different
chunks.
Uh it does also make me
it makes me separate out stuff from the
C++ a little bit more,
but I probably am going to want to do
that anyways, right? I'm going to want
you to be able to use each segment.
The alternative is what? So the
alternative is that I
I just do cuda graphs myself
manually.
This will add quite a bit of code to the
C++ that would have to be maintained.
Don't have to deal with torch compile,
but it'll also break my nets with torch
compile.
That doesn't seem good. It seems like
because if you want to be able to mix
and match these ops and they should work
with torch compile, right?
So it seems like that is probably what I
need to do. And I think the only thing
So the only reason that this would be a
bad idea is if I go and I do all of this
and I profile and it doesn't actually
get me the expected perf improvement.
Seesh, welcome. Where did I see long
time? Okay, so I'll tell this real
quick. Um, so what happened is I was
getting to be kind of burnt out anyways.
I was going to take some time off. Uh,
and then I got mice in uh in the
warehouse and that was just not a bunch
of fun. So I kind of said screw it on 48
hours notice. Um, booked a flight to
Hawaii and
yeah, I just was there for a week. Um,
and then I like filtered my way back
through, spent a couple more days in
California on the way back and uh went
to visit some family as well in New
England and now I'm back uh in Florida
for the middle of the winter at least.
So that's where I've been
manual isolations. They do it in um they
do it in Python though with this like
mark step and it's absolutely
disgusting. Right.
Wait, why is this under meta pietorrch?
I didn't think this was under meta.
Yeah, this is also not performance
comparable with puffer. Puffer is
ludicrously faster than this.
I think that this chunk of this might be
useful. So
okay. So this this chunk here is
completely redundant if you just write
stuff in C++.
Yeah. So all of this is basically a
negative in my mind.
This is the thing I really need.
Pretty fast for Python. But yeah, that's
the thing. fast per Python. The point of
Python is supposed to be easy. So when
your Python is literally harder to use
and make sense of than if you just wrote
it lowle, you're just an idiot, right?
And this is the problem with a lot of
the stuff in RL right now is like it's
core infrastructure that's written in
Python for the sake of writing it in
Python and it's just completely brain
dead.
That's the problem. Like actually, if
all of this stuff were just written in
C++, I would have no problems. or even
like C or C++. And to be fair, the torch
C++ is really bad C++. So if this were
written in like remotely decent of
either C or C++, uh it would just be
fine.
Obviously, I'd prefer to be closer to
pure C, but like just nothing exists at
the moment. Basically, all these
frameworks are either a mix of C++ and
Python with too much stuff in Python or
uh they're pure Python. And in either
case, the result is garbage.
They do isolations I found interesting.
If you point me to them.
So I mean given this right
the fact that they're compile adds
overhead doesn't this like mean that we
should just do cuda graphs manually
highly educated but also opinionated
yeah that's One of my favorite things
ever to do is like, what is the MIT
PhD's opinion on this? Well, that's
[ __ ] stupid.
It's like, really? You couldn't give me
a more nuanced or, you know, interesting
take than that? You couldn't. It's like,
nope.
Dumb is dumb.
There was absolutely no reason to do it
that way. They did it anyways because
they really like Python.
I mean, there really is there just
really there are no two ways about it in
a lot of these cases. It's just people
putting crap in Python that should not
be in Python. And like you don't get to
just write the same code in Python
versus C. I think people don't
understand that, right? Like there are a
lot of times where you have to write
more code in Python because there are
performance optimizations that you have
to introduce because you're writing in
Python that would not exist if you were
writing in C or C++. So like a lot of
the time when you're doing this stuff,
it's literally easier to just write it
lowle and call it a day
Well, we're not going to look at these
numbers because all of these are super
slow anyways. Um,
but I think that this chunk here, this
is useful cuz I forgot about this,
right? So, this is why
um you get inconsistent speed ups out of
torch compile.
So I think we just go back to CUDA
graphs, right?
Some something. What do you mean there's
some little benefit? There isn't, dude.
Reduce overhead does a bunch of checks
and then calls cudggraph. Those checks
add extra overhead.
And for some reason they do it every
iteration which is like again if they
just did it on the first iteration this
all would be fine.
yeah, this is just going to be doing the
exact same thing as I'm doing, which is
calling all the transfers non-blocking
and then synchronizing after you've
initiated them all.
Sweeping, does it run on its own? And
then I'll get my own parameters. Yep.
Uh, that's how it works. All the
parameters just get tracked on Neptune
and Wii. You go look through your
experiments. You decide what ones you
want. You just copy them over for now.
There's actually there is a utility in
Puffer 4 that's going to make you be
able to load them up in a visualizer and
then just click on the data point you
want to copy. Um but that's not there
yet.
Memory intensive speedups not memory
friendly. Yeah, that's cudigraphs
though, dude. Cuz have to keep the
buffers around, right?
Well, this is annoying because like I
was thinking, well, the way to do it
would be to stick to the way the Torch
is doing it and just expose my networks
and stuff, but I mean with what I'm
looking at here, that's not going to be
enough. And I'm going to have to do this
gross graphing stuff anyways,
right?
But then I also don't get the max
autotune kernels which is annoying.
I'm trying to think about the trade-offs
here.
So
the thing I really really did not like
about Torch Compile in addition to um
you know all the bugs and things that
come from it, I really really did not
like that it adds so much startup time
to your program
because think about it right like I want
the unit of compute uh for Puffer to
become the sweep, right? I want you to
be doing full sweeps and adding a ton of
startup time uh is really not great for
that.
I could technically go through and try
to figure out why torch is so slow and
all that, but
it's such a bloated library that it's
really not even worth it. Um,
so
The other thing I suppose is
so if I do CUDA graphs
presumably I could swap the back end at
some point, right?
Like if I wanted it to be not torched
for the back end.
create the cool graph slowly
for compile back end uh I know of
default reduce overhead max autotune and
max autotune no cuda graphs I don't know
any of those that would do that
from what I've seen, they're all just
super slow, man.
And I don't even think creating the
graph, the thing is I don't even think
that creating the graph should be hard.
Like I think it's just because of
Python, right? Cuz compile only does
like default compile does two things.
You eliminate um Python overhead, which
you could just not write it in Python to
begin with. So that's useless. And
uh it runs cudggraph, but running
cudigraph should just be like that
should be one forward pass.
Like am I wrong or aren't cudigraph
super quick to create?
Like
here
how much uh over
expected compared
to the
build
graphs.
They aren't quick to detect. What do you
mean they aren't quick to detect?
It's literally a trace.
If you build them yourself, it should be
fun.
What? What do you mean if you like? So
there is literally
CUDA gives you the same trace API as
torch. Like torch is actually a pretty
thin wrapper. Well, not thin. It they
add they add a bunch of checks.
Roughly one forward pass is what I would
expect.
Hundreds of microscs to milliseconds.
This is nothing.
Torch will wait to get a lot of phrases
to better understand things. Yeah. So, I
don't want it to do that though
because Torch will do that. The thing is
in RL Torch will do that. It'll like
spin for a minute and then it'll give
you code that's literally slower than
eager mode like most of the time.
So what I'm thinking here right is I
think that what we should do is we
should just say uh compile can
go away. We just drop compile
and we do cudigraphs
because the thing is I was thinking we
were going to do compile today but I
forgot that it's actually slower than
using cudigraphs native. I forgot they
add a bunch of checks and things and
that you have to use additional uh you
have to just graph anyways basically.
Welcome son of liberty. Merry Christmas.
Today we're attempting to kill off the
cudigraph overhead with puffer 4.
See, this is why I need to stream
because otherwise I don't actually
bother to talk through things out loud
and I miss stuff.
Like you see I was adding all this stuff
here.
So this was the other plan, right? Is
that you compile but you see how gross
this is? Cuz like I don't want to trace
this. This is all Python.
If you do crudographs, use gumball
sampling.
Huh?
For what?
Use gumball sampling for what though?
I hear more than rubber ducks. There are
some people here that do RL.
Okay, Lance? This does not look like
something that exists. I know what
gumball sampling is. I have no idea how
it has anything to do with cudigraphs.
for action sampling.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay. That was something
I was wanting to play with.
That was something I wanted to play
with.
I mean, we're going to profile all of
this as well because we're going to
actually see the thing is nobody has
good profiles on stuff. So, we're going
to get good profiles to make sure
actions are a bottleneck.
Dumbbell softmax. Yeah. Yeah, I'm
familiar with that, man. But then you
brought it up in the context of
cudggraph. So, I was like, huh? That
there shouldn't be anything that needs
sampling.
Back and forth afterwards.
The back and forth afterwards. That's
what uh the C++ and CUDA graphs are for
though. Yeah,
we will have the fastest implementation.
We should be the goal is that we're
pushing 10 mil plus for puffer 4 before
I ship it.
10 mil steps per second
now. And I can do I'm going to do all of
my development locally. I actually now
have a 5070 so I can profile a lower-end
system but I cannot profile it on stream
otherwise it'll crash like lag and crash
the stream because it's on the same
card. So I will do everything except
that on stream.
I know. From what I've seen from the
profile, man, it's like there's just
overhead everywhere.
There's pretty much just overhead
everywhere.
Okay. So, this number is not going to be
10 mil for reference here. Like, you're
not going to ever see this number 10 mil
because this is on this is my new uh I I
bought this desktop because it was a
quick ship. So, this is the 5070
machine. It's good enough for streaming.
It's good enough for local development.
and whatever else. But uh yeah, it's not
like my 5090 machine
multinnomial is slow. Um
I've tried a few different versions of
that, man. It there are it's actually
kind of tough to make that fast from
what I've seen.
Though I have not tried
I think I have been profiling py Python
overhead with it. So I still have to try
that in C++.
Avoid softmax.
Why would you what would you do
different in computation graphs of
torch? Start working tensor library and
see
vulcan. What
vul rendering?
Huh?
Uh, it's pretty much just that torch
compile, they implemented it in Python
for some reason.
Like
torch compile, it should have a C++ core
with hooks into Python cuz like the
thing is you don't have to compile C++
code in the first place, right? You
don't have to trace C++. It's already
compiled code, but you still need to do
CUDAs and stuff and they don't you do
not have the ability to just use Torch
for CUDAs. um from C++ you have to go
through Python and it's really really
difficult to move code across this C++
Python barrier with the way that Torch
has their stuff set up and it's even
harder for compile.
Um so it's just a massive pain and then
with all the overhead and checks that
they add like it's literally slower than
eager mode most of the time and you have
to do a whole bunch of black magic in
order to actually make it work and their
error messages suck.
If we avoid You can't avoid soft M.
What? What? You can't avoid soft max,
dude though. What are you talking about?
Oh, that gumbell softmax sampling thing.
Ah, doesn't that change? Wait, does that
change um the output though?
So if we avoid torch soft, we avoid
torch mult. Yeah, because it's
when that thing came out. Um,
okay.
Yeah, I've done that before as well. Uh
I think that you still like the random
noise still becomes the bottleneck then
is the thing.
Uh,
I think if you do that, you end up
having like I did a whole bunch of stuff
on that before and it wasn't that
helpful if I recall.
Like it seemed like a perf win in the
microbenchmarks, but then it actually
wasn't.
All right. Uh,
cool. What we're going to do, let's get
back to this.
I believe I had
run in the CUDA directly.
So maybe if it's in that uh can you
trace can you trace RNG gen?
We'll figure that out later. We have a
whole bunch of stuff to do before that.
Man, there is CUDA launch overhead right
now and that's like independent and I
have profiled and it is substantial. So
either way we need to do this.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. So this is what I was
starting
puffer all capture forward.
Let's not do this. Let's do Can we do
trace?
I think we can do trace, right? The way
that I want to do this, I don't want
this to be like on first execution,
right? This is the way PyTorch does it.
I think that's really bad design. What
I'd like to have is I would like to have
it so when you instantiate the network,
it also does one pass forward. You have
to tell it the shapes of course. Um, but
then it graphs it.
So essentially you get your overhead on
a knit and not your overhead on the
first few iterations and then you don't
break your profiling.
I think this is the way forward.
And I actually already have all the
buffers, don't I?
I need to clean all this stuff up. But
here it is. Okay. So,
yeah, it was something like this, right?
Initraph
chapter forward.
Welcome everyone from YouTube. Merry
Christmas.
I am back and will be doing quite a bit
of streaming over the next several weeks
attempting to finish 40. Um
I'm going to say at a high level uh the
goals are going to be kill off um CUDA
overhead. That's a big one because that
covers compile and graphing. It's going
to be
miscellaneous performance optimizations
derived from microbenchmarks. So really
good benchmarks um clean up the code a
whole bunch have numerical checks on
everything so we can actually make sure
that this is all done correctly. we have
to find a replacement or a speed up for
RMS norm
and uh that's like most of what is going
to go into Perf and then the other side
is going to be finishing up
constellation which is mostly it's
mostly experimental work um just running
tons and tons and tons of sweeps on all
the ends and aggregating the results
and fixing any problems along the way
and then cleaning up the um the new
visualizer UI for release. That is most
of what will go into 40.
The goal for 40 should be that we have
uh fast, we have pretty simple
uh pretty simple entry to the project.
So, it shouldn't really get dramatically
more complicated despite all this new
low-level stuff. And uh well, I mean, 10
mil is going to be more than a double
speed up from 300 plus all the new
visualizations and stuff. And actually,
I think it's going to be substantially
faster than double cuz like
one of the reasons that I'm doing this,
I'm not just doing all this work so that
we can get double speed.
There's an importance to reducing
overhead in RL beyond just like max
throughput speed. and that is that this
will allow our hyperparameter sweep
algorithm uh to find smaller batch
solutions to a lot of the problems which
would not have been efficient to run
before but are efficient now. So I think
that we're going to see dramatic
reduction in either samples or wall
clock uh from this like more so than you
would expect na naively from just the
performance tests
and then we want to have a good
understanding of how all these things
trade off like that's going to be the
goal.
Okay, so we got CUDA graph here.
This does not seem like the correct
type.
Yeah, you probably just need this,
right?
Oh, yeah. The one other thing I want to
do for 40 is uh I want to get the uh the
puffer a makeover.
He's going to get himself we're sending
him to the spa. He's going to get a nice
massage, you know. He's going to get uh
whatever the hell else they do at spas.
I don't know. And we're going to get a
nice streamlined. Get him some new
animations and some stuff.
He's going to look pretty much the same.
It's not going to he's not going to like
look dramatically different. It's just
going to be a little bit more polished.
And then the thing is that the way that
the model is created right now, it's not
done in a way that makes it easy to rig
animations. So, we're going to have
stuff redone in a way where uh it can
have a bunch of different animations and
it can swim around and do other things.
That's the goal with him.
It's just one little fun thing, right?
I like the puffer.
Stop device.
Really?
Oh, does this get Hang on. OBS buff.
I think that this is my bad, right? I
think I I do this here.
Yeah. See like these are all created
here.
Do they set this at some point? I don't
remember setting it.
Okay. This gets bound
and then we just do
Yeah. So this is why I had this here,
right?
Just have to do
So doing this
observations,
Yeah, I think I've just made a big mess
of this and I This just needs some time
to be cleaned up. Is all right. Um,
We'll just
Here's what we'll do.
This is no good.
Just move this over.
I think we can leave this for now,
but we're going to move towards the
correct direction here.
So
tensor
observations
doesn't get used
terminals.
up lengths up indices. I don't think I
use this right.
Yeah, I don't use this anymore. This is
old.
And then all I need to do is I keep
ends, actions, rewards, and terminals
like this. Right?
Okay.
And then in create pop.
Some of these are going to be different,
right?
I think it's fine for now. What are we
building?
Uh currently I am working on adding uh
CUDA support in C++ to puffer lib
and
I have to restructure some stuff to do
that.
Okay, this does give you your buffers
though.
Yeah, there's so many different ways you
could do this, but it's like
I think this is going to be the correct
one now. I'm quite confident. We'll see.
I really don't like that I don't have uh
kernel tuning as a result of this, but
like realistically,
I don't think I need it. And I think
that this is going to be better anyways.
It's like why am I going to take a
guaranteed big overhead hit and
complexity hit
for something that may or may not give
you any performance.
Uh, let me go.
One moment, Spencer.
I was planning to do a big stream today
though I will be free later.
Is tonight good?
Oh yeah, since we have a lot of new
folks probably here, go ahead and start
the buff the puffer discord or star the
puffer discord star the puffer repo if
you don't mind. It really really helps
us out a lot and um you know the more
that the library just grows on its own
from people watching the stream and
people contributing code and stuff like
that uh the more time I get to spend
developing and the less time I have to
spend on promo and other stuff like
that. I do work on this at least
full-time.
I don't know. Now, do you say you work
on something full-time when
realistically it's much more than
full-time?
Though, admittedly,
I say I've been lazy the last couple
weeks, but that's kind of the point of
taking a vacation, isn't it?
Porn concept.
Hey, I did I did get the C vectorization
done over vacation. All right.
It did get the CV back to work.
Oh yeah, I'm just going to need a ton of
these buffers, right?
I'm pretty much I'm just trying to set
up the uh the graph capture thing
cleanly. And it's a little awkward if
you're not used to it because it
requires you to have all these static
tensor shapes which like if you just
retrofit that onto an existing codebase,
it's going to make a mess. But you can
actually end up having it look pretty
clean. I'm quite sure. We just have to
figure out how we're going to do
and this should not be Horizon either,
right?
What am I trying to do? I'm trying to
get um CUDA graphs in native C++.
So the idea of this, right, is I have
the whole training code now in C++. So
there's no Python overhead, but there is
still CUDA uh CUDA launch overhead. And
that is what graph is going to do. So,
it's going to capture all those
operations and then merge them all
together.
now you still really wouldn't want to um
I guess like the the sort of the next
best thing you would do is what Lenor
does where you do
you keep stuff in Python but you have it
graphed because that would still be one
operation.
But like
that's still too many loops in Python.
I'm pretty sure
yeah I think this is going to just be
better. Python just causes so many
problems and realistically you don't
even get that much from doing it.
Like I'm trying to think what is Python
like what is Python specific that I want
to use and I'm coming up blank.
It's just the fact that the torch C++
API is kind of crappy.
I guess I'll be able to play with it
though once I have this as the baseline.
I'll be able to see like okay if I just
do the graphing in Python like how close
do I get in performance? How close do I
get in startup time? I think this is the
best possible thing I can do though. So,
we should do this first before we try to
do anything else.
All right. So, this is for the graph.
So, what this is supposed to do
puffludraph equals. Yeah, now this is
saved.
So
yeah, this is the chunk right here,
right?
This like this chunk
where you just do
replay graphs.
I mean this is going to take me some
time today for sure.
This is
I'm confused.
Isn't this this is the pointer,
right?
Buffer
capture forward.
weird
weird C++ shenanigans.
I honestly think that once this is
cleaned up, we can make this whole thing
no more complicated than the Python. In
some places, arguably simpler.
return puffer.
Okay, so it's just got to beget.
One day we will just have a nice tensor
C API that actually works.
One day
Um, honestly, the math is going to take
you a while, man. Um,
it's not that math heavy of a domain,
but you do need to at least like at
least have some reasonable understanding
of linear algebra and multivariate
calculus
um as applied to matrices and tensors,
which
if you're not if you're smart but not a
total genius will be uh end of high
school, start of college. The thing that
you can do that's a lot more accessible
but just takes a ton of time is to get
good programming fundamentals in because
most people uh most people in AI are
suffering from lack of being able to
program appropriately more than anything
else and it's much easier to get into
because you do not have like you don't
need any required math background in
order to start. Uh, I have on my X
there's an article that's my guide for
programming in ML that has some very
good pointers because the reason
programming is hard is it's one of the
worst taught subjects. It's really
really badly taught. The way that it's
usually taught in school will actually
pretty much guarantee that you will be a
terrible programmer for the next decade.
So, I would uh I'd take a look at some
of the advice I have there and start
building some small projects and really
trying to just do stuff in the simplest
way possible and build up to more and
more complex things while trying to keep
what the way that you're building things
very simple.
It's Yeah, the articles are going to put
it better than I do. That's why I wrote
them is so I don't have to come up with
an impromptu eloquent explanation on
stream. Right. It's all in those
articles.
is this. I don't understand how this is
um not already a pointer.
You're good. The reason I stream is so
people can ask stuff.
But yeah, getting to be a good
programmer is very hard. It just takes a
lot of time and most of the resources
out there are very bad. So
my guide will cover it, but like
starting out with starting out with
Python is going to be the least
frustrating thing, but then very early
on you want to learn some low-level dev.
And if you do it right, it should not be
a frustrating mess. It should feel very
natural and easy. Um, the problem is
that most ways that it's introduced make
it feel very frustrating.
push library and share
like pie charts with a bunch of
operators and activators.
I mean, I'm pretty sure, man, if tiny
had just written their stuff in C, it
would be very close.
For instance,
The fact that Tiny decided to do pure
Python though is like I get why they do
it, but it really limits you a lot.
It's just really limiting.
I think we're still going to end up
using chunks of their stuff though for
kernels. I have to get back to doing
that at some point, but this needs to be
done first. You know,
I was very pleasantly surprised
um
by some of their stuff though.
I would prefer C, frankly. Um,
C++ simply does not bring joy.
There's really nothing in C++ that I
ever want.
And there are many, many things in C++
that just make life a complete living
hell. So,
and to me like the zen of low-level
programming is that there are very few
tools. You learn how to use them.
There's not an ever never ending stuff
like supply of new things. And with this
very small set of tools, you can just
make things that are fast and simple and
that are much more robust uh than pretty
much any other modern software,
any modern software at all.
Okay, cool.
Construct a bunch of operators and
tests. Yeah. So, you need
So, what do you need in a tensor
library? Honestly, you need a good you
need a good tensor strct,
like an actually good tensor strct. Um,
you need to have
uh a good way of setting up kernels.
You need
like a simple and good autograd.
And I you do need cudigraph support
though that can be introduced later. Uh
you will need cudigraph support.
nice extras include like little
profiling tools and things. Um, those
are nice to have,
but ultimately, yeah, I I think a good
tensor library could be well, I mean,
tiny grat has what 18,000 lines, and I
think that they already had reasonable
stuff when it was below 10,000.
We can probably get the basics done in
less than five.
statement of purpose layout. Um, I wrote
I decided to apply for a PhD, studied
for and took the GRE and wrote my
statements in the span of two weeks. So,
I'm probably not the best person to ask
for that. I mean, it I didn't have a
layout, right? I just like I wrote about
my research is what I did. I wrote about
all the research I did. I wrote about
all the research that I wanted to do.
It was so so so much easier for me to do
that than it was for um like undergrad
applications. Those were just miserable.
Meta AI.
So Meta AI, they use Puffer Lib and I
try to support them best I can. um the
structure of their project, it's gotten
quite big. So, I do my best to support
them in a lot of places, but it it's
gotten big enough where it's very
difficult for me to like actively
support as much as I used to. Um
like for instance, I'm definitely going
to help them integrate Puffer 4 when I
have that, right? So, like they get all
the new Perf benefits, but until then,
it's kind of tricky for me to help them
very much. Um because I think like most
of the problems that they have at the
moment are just with the environment
being slow and the size of the
environment codebase and the structure
of it are such that it's very difficult
for me to help with that.
But uh Meta and Puff Meta AI and Puffer
are like completely independent
companies.
like Puffer is my company. Meta is not
my company.
Hi, Jess. Welcome. Good to see you.
I've heard the uh the chess stuff is
looking really awesome.
Merry Christmas as well.
Yeah, I think Rick meta AI that stuff
will be very nice if they get it to be
clean and fast. Um, I'm going to do the
best I can to help them with that, but
they are also going to have to do quite
a bit of cleanup work.
like and speed is so so so important in
RL and it's really not that difficult uh
to get right but you have to you know
there's certain ways that you have to do
things to get things to be as fast as
they need to Okay.
buffer four. Yeah, it is Rick among
other things. Looking at squared get to
grass program flow C reset.
Um Eric like
it's so when you call uh when you call
vec reset from Python it just calls
reset on every end. So like there like
you don't even need a video because
there's no like there is not any code
defining program flow at all. Like
there's not a big blob of code that
you'd have to read through and
understand. It's all very very succinct.
Um Creset gets called once then it's
just step step and then the individual
environments the individual environments
will reset themselves like they'll call
reset on themselves inside of step when
it needs to be. And that's actually in
the squared example already for you.
No, Jess, I actually I got the
multi-threading to work over vacation.
Um I'm working on CUDA graphs right now.
having Python bindings for C.
All the kernels you have Python binding
for C library,
right? All the well the kernels have to
be written in C, right?
um you a C library should be designed so
that you can use it in C and then the
bindings allow you to also use it in
Python.
So you should not ever be designing a
library like a library should be
designed so that it works with both
languages, right? You should never be
designing a a low-level project with the
idea that it's only ever going to be
used from a highle language.
Okay, what did I do here? Oh, I forgot
to add I forgot to add a couple params
segments horizon.
like the ideal case right is you want to
it the you want to minimize the pain of
bringing code across the language border
between uh C and whatever highle
language but then you don't want to have
to structure the low-level code in a way
that is harder to use from from that
language from the low-level uh language,
right? That's the balance you're trying
to strike
stream doesn't show a lot of coding
agents
more productive. Yes, they generally
that just wastes my time, man.
The models are all the models are very
very bad at programming. You'll see that
I don't use them much or actually I
really don't use them at all. I mainly
just use I've got essentially what's a
fuzzy LSP. It's a really really dumb
fast model. Doesn't do much more than
LSP. And then I use whatever model for
docs.
Why do you say most re researchers are
bad at programming? Because I've lot
I've read a lot a lot of researchers
code. They are terrible programmers.
Almost without exception. There are a
handful of good ones.
I mean, I'm not going to tell you that
big tech engineers are good programmers
either. They're mostly terrible
programmers, too. Like, being good at
programming is hard. And there are very,
very few programmers that are actually
good in general.
I mean, to give you an idea, I feel like
barely competent enough most of the time
to get done the stuff that I need to get
done. And like, from my perspective,
it's like everybody else is just running
around on fire like next to a pool,
refusing to jump into it. It's just
insane.
It's completely insane.
Buzzy LSP anything right? Well, it's
just super maven man. Look like you see
I have tab complete but I don't have
cursor for tab complete right? I don't
have like one of the actually good
models, but you see it's instantaneous,
right? Like as soon as I as soon as I
hit enter, I have a tap complete
available. So the model is very stupid,
but it's very fast. The idea is that it
saves typing, not thinking.
And that's really all I want is I want
something that saves typing, not
thinking.
Like I want to think more, right? And I
want to work less with things that are
poorly designed that people are
incentivized to offload to a language
model because they don't make any sense,
right? Like we should actually put in
work to make things simple and intuitive
and nice to use such that you can reason
about them yourself rather than making
things that don't make any sense so that
like only language models are willing to
put up with them, right?
Like one of these leads us to building
better stuff that we understand that we
can improve over time and the other
leads to a complete lack of control over
anything we're building and just like in
shitification of everything.
Well, this is not imposttor syndrome,
man. This is not like I feel like there
are people out there that are like way
more capable or whatever. I've never had
that, right? I feel like this stuff is
hard. I'm barely competent enough to do
it, but I can make consistent progress.
And I see a lot of people that are like
absolutely not competent enough to do
anything and create more problems than
they solve.
Yeah, that's Jess is totally correct on
that.
It's actually way more common in CS that
people think they're good and just suck.
Bad software design through generative
code. Yeah, don't do that, Rick. It's
not fun. It will make you hate your job.
You will not learn anything.
state.
How on earth can the state be wrong?
State must be num layers batch hidden
size.
Oh,
wait. Huh?
No, man. They all the tools suck.
They're selling a vision that like lazy,
worthless people can be competent
without putting in any work.
It's a lie. They're trying to sell you
something.
uh Jess that's a totally reasonable
thing to leave into the main C file and
not in the H file right like just leave
that in for the C mode debugging that's
totally good to
Yeah, but like some I literally could
not work that way where it's just like
you know you have something writing a
bunch of gar like that's you basically
that is fixing garbage code as a job.
If I wanted to fix garbage code as a
job, I'd go work in big tab.
It's actually one of the unique things
about doing my own thing here is that I
actually get to have full control over
everything and I get to make sure stuff
is good.
What's happened here? I
want to get into RL no Python basic math
high school student want to study
university in the US and work in ML in
the future
that's pretty much where I start started
off man um I have my guides on X these
have all of my best advice in one place
I I would start with this one.
This like if you actually really really
read this and listen to the advice here,
this will save you a tremendous amount
of
like wasted time. Like really everything
in here, you might just glance over it,
but like everything in here uh is
basically a very hard one lesson from
wasting a lot a lot of time.
So, I would read this probably read this
multiple times over the next few months,
you know, as you're learning more stuff.
Um,
and then for RL specifically, I have
this one if you're interested. RL's kind
of cool because you end up learning
low-level dev in the process with all
the puffer stuff these days, and you're
also doing some ML.
If you're interested in more generic ML
though, like CS231N is a good place to
start and that's in the guide as well.
Gotten offers from VC. I mean, I'd have
to actually take meetings willing like
on the basis of trying to get funding to
get offers, but I get a lot of messages
from VCs interested in investing and I'm
not raising
Why would I raise like puffer is
profitable?
Okay. This is not how uh this works,
right?
Yeah. This is not how this works.
Yeah, this is the most LLM usage you
will see me do.
We build custom simulations for
companies
and we train high performance RL agents
on them by integrating with Puffer.
We have several active contracts.
What graphics card did you use?
Uh we have I it's mostly 4090s.
Okay, we'll put this for now. Stupid
thing.
We'll put this in here for now.
I don't like this. Like I don't like the
way that this
macro works either.
I see as more of a service. All right.
So, Liberty, think of it this way. If
Puffer Lib were closed source, this
would be like a really obvious thing
that you could pay for and buy, right?
Like, you know, you like even if it's
it's third party free use behind an API
or whatever, or it's just like a binary,
then it would make sense to have a
simulation development service or
research services or whatever. Okay.
Yes, you can. So you get the result of
that except it's also closed source. So
you're no longer behind a third party
API wall. There's the value.
I'm going to read multiple times.
General interested us doing a great job.
Thank you. Yeah, I would especially like
the bits on keeping stuff simple and not
getting sidetracked by all the fancy
things and like on how to view science
and research as a whole.
I mean, the thing that's difficult is
it's going to take you many years before
you can actually tell which chunks of
stuff are [ __ ] and which chunks of
stuff are not. But just knowing that
there is a lot of it out there is very
important because otherwise like you'll
be banging your head against something
wondering why something doesn't make
sense when a lot of the time it's cuz it
just genuinely doesn't make sense.
Let's do this for now just to like check
this.
I think at 12 I'm going to take a quick
break and um get some more tea.
restroom. Walk around a bit.
And as I say as well um you know Liberty
it's like making money is not the first
objective of Puffer but it is the second
objective
if that makes sense.
And now objective number one is
fix this guild. Put RL on the map. Make
this awesome tech exist and be broadly
available. Objective
number two is throw it on a whole bunch
of useful applications and that should
be profitable. Oh,
How did we get a different error?
That is so weird.
Yeah. And I mean a decent chunk of the
money like the goal with the profit is
like personal gain but then also um if
this does well then that allows me to
fund more research efforts right in
related areas.
seating like
uh it'll be seated by default and see
man
I think it is actually. I don't know. I
actually don't know how that works. I
don't know if in C it's deterministic
unless you specify a time based. I'm
pretty sure it is.
Whatever. This check is a mess. Anyways,
let's just do this
for now.
So, I want to get this before I I break
for uh noon.
Only quick break as well.
Oh. Huh.
Uh, that's kind of weird, isn't it?
Thought there were two buffers.
Oh, you know why? Okay. It's cuz it gets
indexed. I mean dumb. Yeah, it's cuz it
gets indexed. I'm dumb.
I forgot you declare the state for all
M's
must be captured.
Okay, so this is me not understanding
API.
Think Rock should be I don't know if
Brock is smart enough for this.
What's your setup?
Uh, no. Because I said if anybody I
respected replied with like a reasonable
setup and mostly the people who I know
who are pretty good told me like, "Yeah,
this isn't actually going to help you."
And I got a bunch of batshit insane
people telling me stuff that made no
sense.
So
unless anybody is going to give me
something to the contrary,
I'm mostly still con like assuming that
this is just imbecile who have been
convinced by LMS that they now know how
to program when they have absolutely no
idea what they're doing.
Like this is I consider this using this
for dots, right? Like this is me not
knowing what is the what is the function
to get and set the default or get and
set the current string. Right? This is
not me asking how do I implement a piece
of logic
Yeah, Jess. The thing is the puffer core
is going to change so much in 40. Like,
let me focus on getting this thing nice
and compact first.
Cuz if I were to do this right now on
40, it'd be like, eh, don't look at
that. This code sucks. This code sucks.
This code sucks. This code's pretty
good. This code's really good. This code
sucks. yada yada. Um, like the stuff you
see me writing here is not the final
state of it. Most of this is a mess.
Okay. What happened here?
So, presumably
Ah, I see.
So, we're going to have to like the
thing is that this
this forward pass,
it actually writes to different indices.
to inaugurate the release of Fer 4. I
need to go find myself like a good um
it would be like a 3D animation and
character artist I suppose somebody
who's done low poly style stuff cuz I
want to get the puffer I want to get the
puffer tuned up a little bit.
Go Explorer will probably be pretty good
for chess chest but it'll be way better
for very long form games.
Yeah. So, like that is one of the things
that go explore helps with, but it'll be
way more helpful for games with a
million horizon, right?
Or whatever.
puffer lip
cuz puffer the puffer fish.
I mean, look, I could come up with some
ridiculous name for all the complicated
stuff we do, but there's not really any
way to pick a name that describes all
this stuff. So, here, have a puffer
fish. See, it puffs up.
Okay, I'm going to have to figure out
because the thing is there are a couple
errors here, but we also have to figure
out how to trace this. Um,
we have to trace actually probably the
easiest thing will just be to trace both
executions, right? Trace like both
buffers worth of ops.
Oh no, I can't do that. Okay, I'm gonna
have to figure this out then. All
right, I'm going to go. It's just about
12. I'm going to take a quick break. I'm
going to go get myself another big mug
of tea, use a restroom, walk around for
a bit. I'll be back as quick as I can.
Might be 10 minutes
if I'm might be 10ish minutes if I'm
quick. And then we're going to see. The
goal for today is to get CUDA graphs to
work. If we can get codigraphs to work
and get an initial profile today, I will
be happy because I think this is the
last major major unknown technical
thing. We shall see. I will be back
though. Oh, if you're new around here
and you haven't already, please just
start the GitHub repo. It's Puffer Live
on GitHub. That really, really helps me
out. It's free. And other than that, see
you soon.
Okay, just got to get myself a new mug
of tea and I'll be right back.
Hello.
CUDA error button. Optimizing Mario
Kart.
Cool.
This is optimizing CUDA graph pain.
I mean, this really does just feel like
fighting ignorance in some sense because
it's always the case that the easy way
to do stuff, like the way that it's
designed, the way that libraries are
designed for you to use them, they make
it really easy to do stuff the wrong way
and really, really hard to do stuff the
right way.
need a stream to watch and opus. Nah,
you don't need opus, man.
Need to make stuff simple.
Thank you, Anes.
It was nice. And of course, the first
day I'm back, I remember why I needed to
vacation dealing with this crap.
Okay, so we can figure this thing out
first.
Gem and bias error.
Transpose map one
to zero.
MNK.
This looks like correct shapes to me.
No.
Hey, Quinn.
Yeah, I took a vacation.
Much needed.
Okay. So we get the error here
it's stay contiguous.
Okay. Okay. So the inputs
the inputs are continuous now.
I don't really watch um TV or movies.
Why use Grock? It's built in and it's
fast. It's very stupid though. I will
say I honestly think Grock 4 is worse
than Grock 3.
It's like really stupid.
But I'm only trying to I just need a
model for fuzzy docs. So most of the
time it's fine. I'm not actually using
it to write code.
I write the code.
mind upload.
Oh man, I think the only good sci-fi
like the only sci-fi series I've
actually enjoyed is the Culture series.
Like most sci-fi is so egregiously bad.
I um
my main forms of entertainment, right?
Like I don't really watch TV or movies
much. I mostly I listen to books and I
play games. And when I listen to books,
uh it's mostly fantasy because you'd
think, oh yeah, sci-fi, what about that?
But it's mostly just so egregiously bad.
Okay. So this should give us a new
error.
Um okay.
So this is same error
two learn that grateful really enjoying
learn ML welcome
yeah the uh CS231N will have you do that
um
you definitely want to understand the
concept cept of autograd and like per
layer gradients
cuz if you try to naively do like back
properly the whole net at once you're
not going to have a fun time.
Sam Alman tweeted how good that is not
an anthropic. You're not selling it very
well.
You're not selling it very well there at
all, man.
Okay, so this thing is dumb. Let's get
rid of this.
We'll try again.
Paste the exact same error.
Tiny Torch is awesome. Yeah. Yeah,
that's very good. How do you read this?
Okay, then these terminal fonts. This
one, man. I made this. This is like my
personal theme.
Might as well bleed if you put it on a
white background.
I mean, this is just like off black, you
know, slight cyan background with um
cyan, white, and red
like font.
You can go try it out if you want. The
config for this is in buffer tank.
warm-up needs to happen on the same
stream.
think the capture stream not the
default.
Okay, let me try this.
So
just do an additional
synchronize
Okay.
See if this does anything different.
Why can I not see?
Oops.
Oh my gosh. What the hell is that? If
you type twitch.tc, it takes you to a
spam site.
Uh yeah, I'm live and I have no idea why
it's doing this. I think it's just
Twitch.
It was fine earlier today.
It's got my uh it's got this stuff here.
Error
Oh, okay. It's the bit rate. Hang on.
Let me see. Hopefully, this doesn't
restart the stream, but I got to fix my
bit rate.
Does it let me do that without
restarting? No, it doesn't.
We'll let that I'll do that after then.
It'll just Well, no, wait. It does. It
does. Hang on. 6,000 kbps. Apply.
Okay.
We'll see if that fixes it.
Okay. Well, that may or may not get
applied. I we'll see if it fixes itself
in a bit.
What do you recommend after CS231N
autograph something that automates?
Should I expect things to get easier?
Yes, obviously things will get easier.
This explains to you how things actually
work so you're not blindly treating
PyTorch as a black box.
Um,
honestly what I did is like I read
papers, I implemented papers, I did
projects, I did my own research, right?
It depends if you're interested in
general ML or RL, right? Like with RL,
we have tons of stuff around puffer liib
and I have extensive guides for that.
For ML, like what are you interested in?
Go do something in that area.
As long as your interest is not training
the biggest possible language model
because then I hope you have a quite
large budget.
change something on OBS and restart it.
Yeah, I don't want to restart the stream
for that because um maybe I can just
restart the Twitch stream. Hang on.
I think this will let me just restart
Twitch.
Yeah, there we go. Cool. Fixed. Thank
you for that.
very dopamine intensive, man. With all
the stuff I saw on
I with all this the tweets I saw from
the freaking uh Runescape guys on on X
for Christmas, it took so much
self-control to not download that again.
Like I that game is just straight
heroin.
RL is not yet fixed. I get to play more
games when RL is fixed.
I did download WoW over vacation, but by
comparison that's like
not remotely close.
Okay, so this is the exact same error.
Um,
let me see what we can do about this.
So,
more iterations.
I highly doubt that changes anything,
but we'll try it. It should just need
one.
upgrade RL RS bots.
Yeah, except that I'm not going to go
break my favorite game here, man. Like,
I'm not going to go ruin my favorite
game with more bots.
I'm pretty sure that is the game that I
have the most number of hours in.
Let me see what this is.
Capture begin.
Why sonnet?
I'm I'm using fuzzy docs. Okay, I just
need docs. Like I don't want it to write
any real code.
Like I basically just need something to
tell me how to set how to set up
photograph correctly.
Any model that does not have me waiting
for minutes between calls is cool.
Nitrogen.
It doesn't even run real time, man. They
apparently they um they like sped it up
for the demo
or like they um they removed all the
pauses or whatever.
I don't know. Like Nvidia is cool, but I
kind of just ignore everything from Jim
Fan.
Hope this is faster.
Oh, cool. I don't even I don't even have
a um a subscription though. I don't
really feel like getting one either. I
don't really feel like um
like supporting either of those.
The thing is I don't actually like use.
It was weird. I don't know what happened
cuz the latest Grock update made it
super super dumb. It was actually pretty
much fine before.
I mean to be fair though like this is a
test cuz so far this is like this is
still pretty dumb as well.
Did I remember to recompile? This is why
I have to
not pay so much attention to chat.
I think I did though.
So, I think this is some completely
different error, right? Yeah, it got to
be a completely different error.
Give us a real error. No
torch. Use cuda DSA.
Um, so not it depends what layer you're
simulating, right?
The idea is they have some real data,
but like you can do pretty much the
whole planning part in sim.
Like multiple real driving companies are
using um the uh puffer drive sim now.
You basically need way way way less
human data if you have a fast sim for
training.
Where would the real data come in in the
um well there are multiple ways you can
do it right?
So one is mapping vision to state like
in an encoder type thing. Um
like obviously that you either do you
either have to do state estimation or
you do it end to end but like either way
you can still use you can still use the
fast sim for planning.
Like there are a lot of situations
there are a lot of edge cases and
situations where you just need a ton of
human data to get that you can easily
just do in sim and then really the only
difference between
uh the sim and the real world if the sim
is at least somewhat decent is the input
modality. So that can be done
separately, right?
Have a separate embedding model.
I'm go ask some of the um the NYU guys
because I don't know to what extent like
information is public but
the project itself's open source
the heck.
Let me see what the heck this is. It
just r so much stuff.
blah blah blah blah blah blah.
I think it errors before this, doesn't
it?
I think it errors before this. So, this
doesn't work.
this right.
Well, let me try this. But I'm pretty
sure maybe it does on second iteration
or something.
Does this give us anything? No, it
doesn't give us anything. And the reason
it doesn't give any us anything is
because the error happens
right here.
Okay.
There happens right there.
Hey, Tim. Yes, thank you. There is
Puffer Drive. Yeah. So, Puffer Drive is
the whole codebase, man. It's all open
source and they just have um
well, I don't know if it's actually been
done yet officially, but there is a big
release
If you give it a couple days,
it's all there already though. But you
know, there will be a lot of material
that you can read uh quite soon.
I don't see how this does anything
though because like
I actually don't know what either of
those companies do but um
so I uh the professional side of Puffer
is we build high performance simulations
for companies and then we integrate them
with Puffer's open source tools. So like
all of our general stuff like it's all
open source. It's not open core, it's
full open source, but then we build
custom sims for companies in a variety
of areas. You'd be surprised the amount
of different stuff you can do. Um
like the environments that we have are
actually very good benchmarks of whether
stuff works or not.
Well, this is completely brain dead.
So, so far it's like, oh yeah, Brock's
really stupid. But this is actually
pretty stupid, too.
lab would you pay sub for?
I mean, I already have Brock. Um,
like I'll get stuff if it's dramatically
better, but Elliot, my experience, my
experience has thus far been that all
the models are really stupid and it's
like mostly just bad devs fighting over
like leap like basically leaprogging or
hopping to new models every couple
months whenever the labs release a new
one. Like the models are all just really
dumb.
Like I have this is like a oneline bump
somewhere here.
It is probably this I would think.
Right.
See this is like this is flailing.
Disable
to not use workspace allocations.
Yeah, but you can't do this. This is
stupid.
I don't know, Elliot. I might go get
Gemini or something eventually, but
man,
loose cases, low-level logical sims,
kids chip design.
Yeah, if they're fast, if the Sims are
fast or can be made fast, then
absolutely.
We had initial discussions with at least
like one similar company um a while ago
like before puffer was anywhere as good
as it is now.
Not forms but not for ideally RL. Yeah.
The thing is like the Sims have to be
fast. That's the main requirement for
RL. And like it's not like your Sim has
to be fast now, but we have to be able
to do the napkin math and say, "Oh yeah,
I can make a fast sim for Right.
And right now it's ideally you want the
sim to be fast without a ton of
hardware. That will change in the future
uh as puffer gets more stable like cuz
the experiment outcomes will become much
more consistent and predictable.
But for now it's like fast sim problems.
But l I'm not trying to get the thing is
I'm not trying to get it to write me
code. Like you see it's outputting this
whole thing but I need one line of this.
Like I literally just need to figure out
what is this graph capture error or why
like why can't I get a full trace
Can it be robust
logic rules?
Yes, because the the thing is I the the
logic part is done by the sim, right?
The agent just takes actions on the sim.
Those actions can be validated by the
sim itself. So it's not fuzzy in that
sense.
focus. Opus. Do I even have that?
It's a subm model, man.
I mean, I could go get one of the other
ones, but like this is this is literally
docs. This is this is knowledge
retrieval. This is not even something
that should have to be thought about.
Can I do this?
I don't I think this is a device side.
Does it actually let you get to the ex
the catch or is it doing something
weird?
current limitations of buffer lib.
Well, as of 3, right, it's just like
we're hitting all of the performance
limitations of torch itself. Like torch
just doesn't let us go as fast as we
want to from their Python API. Um,
we're getting limited by kernel fusions.
We're getting limited by launch
overhead. We're getting limited by
compile overhead. We're getting limited
by uh inability to profile. we're
getting limited by like some specifics
of the architecture we were using. It's
kind of they're just limitations
everywhere. And in Puffer 4, the goal is
that we actually have stuff done lowle,
low overhead with accurate monitoring of
actually where we are spending each
chunk of our compute. We get 10 million
steps per second and that helps us quite
a bit. Like that will allow us to run a
ton of experiments. We definitely need
better tools for running not thousands
but like tens or hundreds of thousands
of experiments. Uh we have those now and
we have a beta version of constellation
which is going to be the new
visualization dashboard.
So this should get us a ton of good
insights.
Um now there are still some core
algorithmic limitations that we have to
address but those are going to be much
easier to address once we have just
higher confidence in general in the
field. Um, so puffer 3 was a much higher
confidence I would say than puffer 2.
Like when we use puffer 3 for something,
we understand the problem better. We
have a better way of solving and
approaching things. There's less
fiddling. So puffer 4 is similarly.
There's going to be higher confidence,
less fiddliness about it on new problems
than in puffer 3 and much faster.
Operation failed due to error dur to a
previous error during capture.
Okay, so this annoys me because
I mean I tried grock whatever it is
latest Grock I've tried this is not a
model problem man this is a doc's
problem
this is not logic this is knowledge
man, Carpathy is usually good, but he
has some also very questionable stuff.
Very smart guy.
I mean, like, I can't possibly disagree
with this more. like
the I have still I have not seen a
singular good dev produce something like
genuinely good with all of these fancy
tools and Carpathy has produced several
things that are genuinely good without
these tools.
So I just like this doesn't make sense
to me. I feel the exact opposite. I feel
like everybody else is mostly wasting
their time, spinning their wheels,
refusing to actually learn anything
deeply and just hoping that AI will
think for them.
and like I mean the proof of this right
is if the if the portions of as a
programmer if your contributions are
becoming increasingly sparse that's not
you becoming a better programmer right
that's just you losing all of your value
that is you having zero additional value
whatsoever
I mean, he coined the term vibe coding,
right? And it's a complete disaster.
I don't know. It really feels just like
a bunch of lazy idiots have infested the
field
more than it does anything else.
I mean, I'll reconsider when somebody
shows me something genuinely good, but
every single time somebody like claims
to have something really good that they
vibe coded up or whatever, um, even if
they're an experienced engineer, it ends
up being completely wrong. I've seen
this happen many, many times. Cuz the
thing is like
programmers are not the most social
type. All right? We're not very good at
telling when people are lying to us. And
the one thing that LM are superhuman at
is lying. They just lie their asses.
They're very good at convincing you of
[ __ ]
Like see this model here it literally
does not understand an if statement
and these are supposed to be superhuman.
It doesn't understand that the error
right is happening here and that means
this doesn't get executed.
But yeah, they just they don't even run
the test. They just pretend that they do
and then they lie. It's
I don't know to some extent these models
they feel architecturally stupid.
You shouldn't need any of this [ __ ] It
should just be
get last error.
Let me see what this what's up here.
So message
no error code zero
operation failed due to a
Okay. So this is very weird.
Let's get rid of this model is dumb.
Okay. Um
Are these not CUDA temps? Hang on.
They not make these on CUDA upstate.
No, these are food tensors,
right?
These are both good tensors.
Yeah, but like the thing is, okay, if if
these things are super human on
benchmarks and then they're completely
useless on relatively simple tasks
elsewhere, like you just have very
shitty benchmarks that you're hacking.
Like we've seen the same thing in RL. It
really feels like LM bros are just
managing to repeat the worst era of RL
research, but now will burning billions
of dollars.
Uh, yes, Liberty, but it's dramatically
more of a pain in the ass to set all
that stuff up um with something like
this than it is with a pure Python
program.
There's like actually a pretty
sophisticated stack of stuff here.
It's cool that RL is being used on
language models, but like RL's RL is
useful completely independently of
language models. Like we can decide that
we actually don't need to RL language
models tomorrow and there will still be
plenty of useful things to do with RL
develop. See, taste itself is like a
[ __ ] ass concept as well. There
isn't like there's not a thing of taste.
It's not subjective. It's like there are
regions that are subjective, but the
vast majority of things are objectively
stupid.
It's not like the person that was
developing this library had poor taste,
so it's bad. It's the person who was
developing this was a [ __ ] programmer,
so it's bad.
Concise is a good one. There should be a
strong bias towards simplicity. There
should be a strong bias to using fewer
things well rather than many things
poorly. Um, you know, there should be a
recognition of performance targets for
what you are building and what is needed
for them.
next 510. Um, so in RL I think the
longer term which five or 10 is longer
term at this point is biological sim and
material science like getting this stuff
into uh not just like quy the LLM please
solve cancer for us but can we build
high performance sims and uh use them
substantially like for substantial parts
right of research.
LSTM is a better core. LSTMs are a
better core than not having LSTMs for
RL. Um, like not having any sort of
memory. We're currently messing around
with mining. Mining is likely to be the
core of our next uh architecture here.
Yeah, Robin, that's kind of what I feel
like as well. It's basically just like
people who have absolutely no skill or
value whatsoever attempting to ascribe
themselves some value in the use of
tools that they don't understand and did
not build.
I mean, I consider myself quite
arrogant, and that's just like a
completely different level of arrogance,
right? That's just like off the charts
delusional.
Like the type of arrogance I have is I
don't know what I'm doing half the time,
but I know I'm at least in a better
position to figure it out than virtually
anybody else. Right.
compile with this CUDA error stream
capture invalidated?
I mean this I looked at this page,
right? Did I not see this?
Get something out of like Stack
Overflow.
Let's
For anybody new around here, I do like
to mention um if you want to help me out
for absolutely free, just start the
repo. Feed the puffer a star. Look, I
literally made an RL environment about
puffers eating stars. That's got to get
you to start the repo, right?
I don't like being stuck on dumb things
like this.
I'm stuck here because I don't have a
proper error message and I don't
understand why I can't get a proper
error message,
right? Because this doesn't run. So, cud
to get error string doesn't run. If you
run it here, it says it's empty.
But how is there a previous
Well, of course it's because of the
graphing, right?
Maybe I can see this.
Okay, so this see it's here, right? Like
this is literally the first layer
encoder forward observations, right?
So, it's breaking on.
How can it be breaking on the first
layer
with graphing on? I mean, it must be set
graphs up wrong, right? Like
actually. Is there um is there an
example pytor cuda graph C++
capture must occur on a non-default
stream.
This I could be doing this wrong, right?
Because this is probably the default
stream.
You know, I just need like a little um
sample bit. Actually, let me try one
thing. I bet You know what? I bet you
that this thing didn't do um Oops. I bet
you this thing didn't do it correctly.
Hang on. I have an idea.
stream guard stream get stream from
pool.
time with tiny. So far so good. I need
to spend more time with it. Right now
I'm fighting other demons.
It's like it's good enough that I think
we're going to probably go start using
chunks of it, but it's not good enough
yet that I can just swap it in in place
of torch. It doesn't have the
performance
Yeah, the design of it is like the
design of it is quite good. I think
overall I wish it weren't implemented in
pure Python. I wish it were actually
like implemented in C or minimal C++.
Um
there are some things that that causes
as well that are annoying, but
Yeah, this is supposed to get us a
trace.
Hang on. Like look, this is supposed to
give me a trace, but it just doesn't.
I'm trying to think what I can do about
this, man.
Anybody know? Like
the thing is there's just very little
example of what I should be doing with
this
like graph.
So I am using this is torches graph
wrapper right.
Honestly, Nvidia stuff is like way
better.
This is actually pretty nice,
but apparently there's some conflicts
that catches
this? Maybe this.
Let me just make sure real quick that
this doesn't do anything.
Anything
Okay. What do we get now?
We get the same thing
on
Okay. I mean, this is not going to be
useful, but we'll do it anyways.
cuz maybe it is. You never know. I could
have messed something up. I don't think
it was possible, but I could
definitely not make shreds. I love I
like how by the way like it can't even
get um a oneline
torch check call right without
hallucinating methods
that don't exist.
OP shape
ops can take
let's try and Back
Yep.
It's all fine.
I can try this. Do we have Do we have
this?
I'm going use the restroom while uh
while we do this and go grab myself
another cup of tea.
Okay, here's what we're going to do.
We're going to make a small neural net,
just like a one layer thing, and we're
going to see if that works, cuz
otherwise it's it's got to be something
with just the uh
the API, right?
welcome Quinn.
Um,
yeah. So, we can do like this, right?
Wait, what?
Oh, come on.
I swear it just went and installed the
wrong
I should have checked.
Yeah, I know I have 13, but why the [ __ ]
does it just Why does it install the
wrong version when I go to install?
That's so dumb.
Does anybody know how to fix this? Well,
I mean, I can just install this one.
Just installs conflicting drivers.
Okay, but the idea is we're going to do
like a tiny little network and we're
going to see if this works.
I guess we'll have compute sanitizer as
well in case we need it.
All right. Enough of this.
Come on.
So I think
if this works, we can just incrementally
like keep testing stuff with bigger
chunks of the network until we have it.
If this fails,
then we know there's something wrong in
the setup, right?
right? Isn't this [ __ ] There's no
reason you'd need to warm up cudigraph
capture.
Oh, I guess it's because pietorch might
do something different, right?
Okay.
I honestly at this point I just wish I
didn't have to use torch. I wish we had
just a library that was good, but
there's nothing.
Largest uh industry now like biggest
like AI is billions and billions and
billions of dollars and we do not have a
decent tensor library.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah. So, we should not have to warm it
up.
Okay. So that'll be good, right? Because
then we won't have to do any warm-up and
it'll just be one forward pass.
So basically we will have the equivalent
of well we'll actually have the
equivalent of a very sophisticated
compile
um a very sophisticated sophisticated
compile setup
Okay, so this is yet different thing.
Still better though.
This will be much more consistent.
Okay, does this compile now or are we
going to be stupid?
I have CUDA 13 on here.
Dude, I hate this [ __ ] So obnoxious.
This is why I always do everything in
Dockers, by the way, because now I'm
just like kind of screwed.
Well, I just installed this actually.
Do I just have to
No,
I just installed this and still not
showing
Well, now I no longer have a working um
machine. So, that's lovely
the version being installed was
compatible. I just assumed it would be.
Yeah, that'll break my system, dude.
That'll break my system. that'll like
the stream will end and I will not have
a computer today.
I don't understand how this is still.
I just installed 13. Why is it still
showing 12?
I'm going to have to move this onto
another machine otherwise. Yeah, because
this is going to be I'm going to have
like this is not going to survive. All
right, so lovely. I literally have to
move to a different machine because
otherwise I'd have to reboot.
Good job.
Well, duh. They're all first world
problems. They're still problems.
If anything, they're problems. more
directly related to why the [ __ ] we're
stuck in the current area rather than
sci-fi utopian future.
Uh, this is a new machine. I need to go
get a token.
I mean it absolutely shouldn't just like
[ __ ] install a it should not
automatically go and fetch the wrong
version of the toolkit that will break
your system.
Okay, let me go get the Let me go get a
token. Now, we're going to have to
quadruple authenticate everything.
Lovely.
I'm sure. So, give me a few minutes,
folks. I'll get this on to the 5090
machine and we'll uh we'll go from
there.
Go find my phone.
Okay.
One of these.
What's wrong?
Oh, okay. This is legitimate airful.
We're back. We can get this done.
Okay, this thing is [ __ ] stupid.
Lovely.
Are you only supposed to move modules?
But this is a module. So, how does that
make any bloody sense?
And what the hell is this?
Yeah, this is garbage.
This is a garbage. We don't care about
this. Right
We are going to get something to work
today. I swear it's like
it's like I almost can't afford to um
not have stuff working
cuz there's really nothing more
demotivating than like working hard all
day and getting nothing done because the
tools you're working with just suck so
much.
Okay. It's supposed to be like this.
This is supposed to be it.
We will be able to see quite soon what
is wrong with the graphs.
I mean, you just see the comedy of
errors, right? like every little
possible thing.
But this is why we like this is why
I mean this is why I work so hard
building this stuff because it's like
I don't know what would be more
demotivating right in some sense if
everything in the world were actually
built competently and you basically had
no ability to improve anything
meaningfully as an individual because
everything is done correctly or uh If
things are done comedically terribly and
actually pretty much anywhere you look,
you can just like massively massively
improve everything.
Yeah, there it is.
Okay.
Well, let's get the let's get the whole
trace command right.
Okay. So now we know,
now we know for sure
1084. Oh, wait. What's this?
1084.
Oh, we don't get line numbers here.
Hang on.
Let me compile this with debug.
Oops.
Welcome FPR. Welcome
Merry Christmas.
pretty much towards the end of any block
of work in which I need to do
uh what the hell pretty much uh any end
of block of work in which I've been
working on ridiculous things for a very
long time.
Okay, this debug equals one is really
annoying as well.
Do we have line numbers?
We do have line numbers. Perfect.
So right here, you see we got line
numbers right there.
First thing I want to get rid of this.
See what happens.
Yeah, now we're actually going to be
able to make progress because now I know
it's a setup issue, right? Because it's
not the whole network, it's one linear
layer.
So this should be the real error, right?
Message
I don't see them initial instantiating
couplass.
Okay, let me just see if it is the
warm-up
horse.
still get the same error.
No. So we actually we get a different
error.
Yeah, I mean this is actual usage at
least of the library.
down here.
This
do it though
But this could be eating I guess this
could be eating some of the error check
handling.
Actually does not synchronize right.
Maybe that breaks it.
on side stream.
This one is using a separate stream.
again
CUDA error
stream capture invalidated and we get
this one on. It's the same line.
Yeah. So we get
That's not very much information in
video.
right so this is let's where's this this
uh tutorial doc from so
a cuda cuda graph
Okay, so we get this graph, right?
And then
graph static cast
graph star.
Yeah. Okay.
And then we do what is it? Graph capture
begin
frame step.
I'm going to copy this chunk exactly
because this is from the PyTorch
tutorial. Unless Grock has something for
me.
Nope. Groc is stupid as usual. Cool. I'm
going to run I'm going to try this exact
piece of code. So, I'm going to do like
Do they have a guard? They do not have a
guard.
Okay. So, what we're going to do is
we're going to do like
wrap
and then we're going to do
I think I might have been mixing the um
the Nvidia and the torch functions.
Let's see.
And then I can just comment the rest of
this crap for now.
And
just take this exit as well.
Like this.
actually don't which is this pass to
both.
Wait, 12.8. Oh, yeah. No, cuz it's
supposed to be 12.8 on this machine.
I thought it was maybe um a compiled
arc, but it is actually just um
Yeah. Oh, well, I'm dumb. Of course it
is. We're in this room now apparently.
Ah, okay.
usually caused by CUDA meopy async
failure.
Yeah, right there.
So, we have this.
I mean, this seems like a setup error
now, right?
Okay,
let's see what we have from this.
I guess we can try this real quick,
right?
I just want to compile this as a
standalone.
Uh, this one, this is an SSH session
5090.
And there, I mean, there you go, right?
490. Was it 49 59? Yeah, it's 590 bucks,
right?
It's not preference. You're just
trolling if you're not working on Linux
for this type of stuff.
Oh, dummy.
Yeah, that was brain dead. Okay.
So [ __ ]
Now it doesn't have contact.
Okay, so this one works.
That's what I needed to know.
so this is the exact same piece that I
have from before. Okay. So what we're
going to do,
we're going to make this exactly the
same.
I need a restroom real quick. I'll be
back in uh I'll be back in a minute,
guys. We're going to get this to work.
This is just a mass
we're going to make this actually. Let's
go for exactly identical, right?
We're going to take this exact freaking
code.
How many programming languages do you
know? I don't know.
two useful programming languages, C and
Python, stuff I've worked with like
ever. Java, C++,
um, UDA,
[ __ ] else, C.
Did I say JavaScript? I guess that
you can kind of pick up new languages in
a couple of days most of the time.
That's like a completely irrelevant
measure though.
The only wrong answer for that is one if
it is JavaScript or Python or two if
it's JavaScript and Python
for the most part.
If you write C, then you'll be right at
home because we have I mean Puffer, I
don't know 30 40,000 lines worth of C
games and simulations that we use for
reinforcement learning.
Mhm. The mug would be would be able to
be smaller if I did not have to debug so
much complete and utter [ __ ]
But I need a big mug to keep me through
this.
if this fails, then we have a setup
error of some type,
not an actual error in the code.
Okay, we have a
we have a setup error of some type. Love
link.
What was your You'll have to retype it.
If you tried to link something, it
probably chomped it.
If I don't see your question there
though, I didn't see it. Like, if you
don't see it up there,
You can post it in Discord if you'd
like. It's discord g/puffer.
Okay, it's the freaking environment
somehow.
Somehow when we create the environment
What keyboard do you use?
I think it's Was it this thing?
uh Widow V4 75% with orange switches.
It's like medium clicky.
I also have um you know a compressor and
stuff so
How do I get into this buffer stuff? Not
technical.
Well, you'd have to pick up some
programming first of all. Um,
I mean, the context here is I'm I'm an
MIT PhD in reinforcement learning,
right? I've been working on this stuff
for a very very long time. We do have
people who were not technical and did
get into puffer though it definitely
took some effort. Um, a lot more effort
I'd say than if you come in at least
knowing some basic programming.
I have some guides
like all of my best advice for newcomers
is on the articles.
This is probably the best one here to
get started. Now, this doesn't actually
direct you to a specific course or
anything. This does save you a lot of
time though if you're new to programming
because like this really has all my best
advice. This will like save you a ton a
ton of time learning. So, you probably
should at least get some basics here and
then once some of this starts making
sense. I have my RL guide here and this
does actually take you through the
process of building a simple
environment. Um, but it is going to at
least the starter sections are going to
assume that you have some programming
background.
Um, and it refers you to other materials
as well.
I mean, I don't like to jam the
credentials, but the point is like this
is a very advanced area of research. Um,
the good it was completely inaccessible
two years ago. The good news is it's
getting a lot simpler. Uh, I'm working
very very hard to make this a lot
simpler, but there's still definitely
some stuff you need to know. It's not
the type of thing where you can just
like download a thing, run it, and have
it work. Um, at least not with custom
stuff, though. It's actually getting
pretty close. You still need to know
some stuff. There are a lot of new
people in the Discord as well that are
pretty helpful.
MIT recognized your work.
Well, I mean, I have
like I have the PhD, right? So like Yes.
we just I think I have an idea on what
might work for this. Can I just do
CUDA device synchronize?
civil engineering and different trade
school.
Hey, trades are very respectable, man.
We honestly we have we have a ton of
really [ __ ] engineers around that do
negative work.
I don't think I've ever met a plumber
who does negative work.
If I just do C to device synchronize
and try something.
I bet you this does something, right? If
we just Let's put this back.
I'm Joseph.
I am a researcher in reinforcement
learning. I'm building a stupidly fast
library that lets AI play games at like
10,000 times real time and learn uh and
learn to play them by doing it.
It's used for a bunch of other stuff.
Yeah. And there's honestly like
even at the top schools, it's only a
fraction of the people that come away
knowing anything useful.
I honestly think a lot more people would
be way happier
um going to trade school than trying to
do stuff in tech that's like total
[ __ ]
Like I mean because the thing is
university really doesn't teach you a
lot of the practical stuff. You're way
better learning you're way better off
learning most of that on your own
anyways.
Um
although I am in tech, I did not get any
of it. Yeah, that's about right.
Um if you want demos, we have them at
puffer.ai. You can like play around with
our agents.
It's just like you can think of it as we
train small models on games and we train
them ludicrously fast.
We don't just train on games. We train
on other types of sim. But for research,
we use games.
Well, let's so that we can do this right
now. Let's at least
here we're going to keep the example in
there,
but we're going to just move this
Okay. So, here's what we're going to do,
right?
Okay? And then we're going to
Get rid of a lot of crap.
the policy.
This is fine, right? It's literally just
this chunk. Everything else is just
[ __ ]
Okay, so this tiny little piece of code
is what's been driving us nuts all day.
I will say I had a handful of courses
that were very useful in my undergrad,
but most of them were a massive waste of
time.
Learned Android dev, one of the phenomen
jobs. Job in hand, not happy with it.
What about other tech?
Um, well, if you if you just learn to
program and you don't just learn Android
development, you should be able to very
quickly pick up other skills, right? So,
pick something interesting with jobs,
learn it, and then try to go get a job
there if you want.
How is Python? What do you mean? How is
Python backed?
How did you learn to program using
videos or books? Honestly, very
stupidly. And it took me a lot longer as
a result. Um, I had some like Java in my
high school and I wrote a bunch of
Minecraft mods. Java is a terrible
language. It teaches you terrible
programming habits. I picked up mat lab
over this one summer doing like really
basic AI stuff and then I started trying
to like write my own neural nets and I
spent a lot of time when I was 16 17
just trying to figure out how to write
neural nets in like mostly Python.
Um picked that up
and I wrote a lot of really bad code for
a lot of years and I spent a lot of
years trying to figure out how to write
better code and most of my like courses
they actually do not teach you to write
good code at all. um they teach you to
write ex exceedingly bad code. So I just
had to get better as a result of doing
my own projects and doing my own know my
own research. Um
and then frankly all the low-level stuff
has just been in the last couple of
years since I finished my PhD because
the amount of engineering that was
required to build puffer uh was
something that I could not do during my
PhD. That was just too much time.
Backend dev and Python.
Yeah, Python backend kind of gross.
No, Java is not good. Java is
like crime against humanity.
That thing should not exist
here. Let me tell you tell show you why
job is so stupid.
This is the project that um I was this
was the project that I was shown
during uh high school when I was like
learning stuff like this was the example
of good code and and stuff and was used
for this. This is like hundreds and
hundreds of files. You can literally
implement this thing in about 300 lines
of C in a couple of hours. And even we
even have like a little prototype. I
never finished it. But like you can
implement that thing about a million
times faster
and like this is a few hundred lines of
code. Like you can like fire, you know,
whatever.
So
yeah,
like the language itself forces you to
write bad code. It's ridiculous.
went to Stanford. Some of your classes
had said to be world class, but
kind of. Yeah.
Thought you were an undergrad. I'm 28,
man.
I finished my PhD almost two years ago
now. And I've been building Puffer ever
since.
This is all open source, but it's also a
company. We do ultra high performance
simulation. and I do a lot of research
in public. So that's the idea around
here is this is like know cutting edge
research uh combination of performance
engineering algorithms
architecture ton of other stuff and I do
it all right here
mostly projects. Yeah.
Okay cool. So observations must be B
input size. Where's my network?
No, not from Stanford. The PhD is from
MIT. Stanford was my undergrad.
Just done for the day. How's CUDA graph
going? Well, we just figured out the
thing that was getting us stuck. Um,
there was this crazy conflict with the
end vectorzation where somehow like some
of the streams are conflicting with
trace. And now I'm in the process, now
that we figured that out, I'm in the
process of reintegrating stuff. Oh yeah.
Yeah. If you if anybody around here is
new, just star puffer live on GitHub. It
really helps me out. It's all open
source. This is when I started working
on it full-time.
Ah,
is this um
Yeah, this is a problem.
How do we do this?
Yeah, this is the big problem, right?
Should I contribute dumbbell sampling? I
was talking about create a good PR. Um,
Lance, can you create what would be
really helpful if you if you just like
made a micro benchmark basically?
Can you get like it should be pretty
straightforward to get a micro benchmark
of um like basically just showing the
perf difference? You can do it in Python
if there's actually a perf difference
there. Um, it would be better in C++,
but you can just stick it there.
And I I just want to see like
I essentially want to see that diff and
like do it under realistic conditions as
well, right? So batches of I don't know
2,000 or 4,000 relatively small number
of lodges, that type of thing.
Public opposition to data centers. Um
the only politics around here allowed
are things that are directly and I mean
very directly AI. Everything else is
like just keep it tech focused. Public
opposition to data centers. I don't
think there is public opposition to data
centers though.
I mean that's all [ __ ] like though,
right? That's I mean that's essentially
just like vested interest bullshitting.
There is no real opposition. It's like
people lying and saying that LLMs drink
a lot of water or [ __ ] right?
on breakout. You doesn't even need to be
be on breakout, man. A microbenchmark
would just be like time the sampling
operation.
Now, you do have to make sure you're not
cashing and you have to make sure that
you're actually getting new RNG or
whatever every time cuz I remember that
I tried this Gumbell softmax a while ago
and I think you just ended up
bottlenecking on RNG generation.
Um,
you're free to like go ahead and try it
though.
Nimbies for data centers.
Well, yeah, that's reasonable. You
shouldn't have a data center in your
backyard, but there's plenty of space to
build them that's not in anybody's
backyard.
So,
like there's a lot of open space in
America.
RNG is fine on our imple. I remember
playing with it a while ago and it not
working. So, if you have a benchmark for
it, then absolutely cuz like what I'm
going to want, Lance, um just to give
you an idea, I've been working on this.
It's in 40 at the moment. Test
microbench. Right. So, I have these
tests of a bunch of different like a
bunch of different it's mostly right now
C uh++ versus kernels, but I'm going to
want to have a very nice benchmark that
has essentially all the custom stuff
that we've done that's nondefault
so that we can see that all of our stuff
is faster and by how much
Neptune going dark because we closed AI.
Yeah, I saw that. So, we're going to
have to switch back to wi
battle environment bonked with current
the one with ocean. Uh, yeah. So, that's
an unfinished environment.
It's not listed on the website. It's
just like unfinished.
I don't remember what state I left it
in. There are some cool screenshots in
the Discord, though. It's like this
large scale environment with a bunch of
vehicles.
enough existential crisis.
Hey, drop by whenever. There's lots to
learn here. Is there PR or something
where I can look up the state?
No, but you can see any of the
environments that you see like if you
see environments here on ocean, these
are stable, right? So, these are the
ones we're advertising that we have and
that are good. And then stuff that's not
in here is well not there for a reason.
Large agent team based environment.
Um,
If you want way more agents though, then
like that's kind of tough.
There's some stuff you can do with the
drone ends. We obviously have snake that
you can hack on if you want to do
something with that for coordination.
Neural MMO similarly like that runs a
lot of agents. You can put them in teams
if you want or whatever.
Dynamic varying agents like park on side
when inactive. Wait large agent team
base setting dynamic varying agents.
Um dynamic and varying agents is
generally a complete and utter pain in
the ass and virtually impossible to do
well from an infrastructure perspective.
It was one of the like the worst
possible things in my PhD. I strongly
recommend not doing it when possible.
You kind of always want to have like a
close to constant or close to constant
number of agents if you can all at all
get away with it.
You lose quite a bit of performance on
virtually any implementation that you
can come up with.
There's a very good reason we don't do
that here.
It's technically
I believe it's technically possible to
come up with a pretty decent one. Um,
you literally need algorithmic level
changes where it's really annoying.
Mask inactive agents. Think of action
masking. Yeah, that thing messes stuff
up. That exact thing breaks stuff, I'm
telling you.
cuz you're messing with your batch
sizes, okay? Like you're messing up your
batch sizes and unless you start with a
massive number of agents and a lot of
ends, if you end up with very few agents
actually active, you end up with these
tiny little batches.
You break a lot of stuff doing that and
it's just generally a pain in the ass.
It's like unless you have a very
specific reason to do it, it's not worth
it versus the large number of other very
cool and useful things you could be
doing
and assigning a credit.
You still you're still getting null data
up. So you're essentially messing up
like your your batches have an uneven
amount of real data or you have a very
small amount of real data compared to
what you expect. There like a ton of
different ways you mess stuff up. I it's
actually there's a decent chunk of my
PhD thesis uh which is online devoted to
talking about that mess. It's not fun.
I'm probably the person who's most
qualified in the world to tell you that
as well. I think probably there might be
a couple other people who dealt with it
to the level that I have, but not many.
Read it this weekend. Oh, it's going to
be very long and boring and repetitive.
I don't recommend reading the whole
thing. There are a couple sections
though. I try You can kind of see me
trying to come up with ways around it
and it's just such a pain in the ass.
Oo, that's actually really gross, isn't
it?
I wonder if I can just do this
Thank
Huh?
What?
That's a real error message.
First real error message of the day.
Yes.
Nice. We get to replay.
So, we actually have to record the graph
correctly uh in order for this to make
sense, which we're not quite doing yet.
But this is solid solid progress.
So, from here, I think I can make stuff
work.
I'll still have to figure out the
environment setup threading stuff, but I
can make things work from here. I'm
using a rest room. Give me a few minutes
and then we will we'll see if we can
crush out a
porch cudigraph or a what is it?
Cudigraphed forward path.
Okay,
I'm starting to get hungry.
Got another hour and a bit with another
hour and a bit in me, though.
Try this.
I want to see if this works
cuz I think you have to crap um enough
bug buff. Not bug
wrap some bug.
So goal here is we capture different
graphs. I think this is the correct
thing that you need to do.
Suppose we shall see
if a lot of stuff hardcoded but
figure it out.
void star is not a pointer to an object,
right?
Can I not just make this a
Oh, and then I guess this doesn't need
to be
kept now.
we don't error until here. Perfect.
Okay.
Perfect.
From disc one or two dimensional.
Okay. Now we uh we're actually in a
relatively good spot.
Yeah, cuz these get allocated like this.
End logits do not need horizon.
Um these get
Okay. And then we need to do uh we need
to actually trace
the copies. I believe
we may as well trace that.
Right.
So what we can do is we can put the
capture begin up to here
like this.
I think we're going to end up being able
to do this with one buffer actually.
Yeah, we'll totally be able to do it
with one. We'll leave it like this for
now though.
So we do like this
logit value state out equal ops
Oh and then we also have to do what is
it? Um
and logs.
I think we're going to end up with a
copy issue, but it's fine for now
cuz it's going to be like obso
you don't need to copy obs, right? It's
going to be end
logs
this.
Yeah.
And value.
It's going to be something like this.
This is very difficult, but like this is
going to pay dividends because
this is going to kill like all the CUDA
launch overhead pretty much.
What does not match the broadcast shape?
Okay.
because I can just copy this can go into
a function.
Oh, no. This is weird. Start plus length
exceeds
Okay. So you copy this into state like
this, right?
1153. Perfect.
Absolutely perfect.
So I think
What we want is this.
Just want to take this.
Okay.
I'm going to take this
Just do like this, right?
Like this
Yeah,
I looked at it briefly. Um, there's
probably some stuff that's pretty old in
there,
I would say. But
I mean, there's also a lot of crazy
crazy groundbreaking things.
I don't know. Figure out how to make a
cool Doom mod would be an awesome
project, like semester project to learn
stuff with, right?
running Doom in Minecraft. I don't know
why people do that, man. Like,
writing an emulator of some type is
probably a very good project, but
there's no reason that you need to write
the emulator in goddamn redstone.
All right? You can be a normal person
and write it in C.
ever thought? Of course, it's possible.
I think isn't redstone touring complete.
It's just it's like a really shitty
emulation language if you think about
it. It's just a really inefficient.
Are these people still building that by
hand as well? If you're building that by
hand, that's like awful. But I you can
literally you can write a compiler that
will output for you
it like whatever you want but instead of
being assembly it's redstone like that
is a thing you can do.
Like technically I'm pretty sure you
could even write a redstone JIT if you
wanted to so that it runs it first the
normal way and then after that it like
it just compiles to assembly
or machine code.
But there's not much reason to other
than it being a fun nerd snipe.
New char.
What?
New chair. Ah. Um, no. I'm just in
Florida.
I am a migratory creature. I work
seasonally.
Um, I actually wasn't like I never even
figured out how redstone worked properly
other than a couple dumb things.
The only game the only games I was ever
like legitimately very good at and
discovering new things before other
people was uh MMOs.
I'm terrible at every other genre of
games.
all the Souls games. Um,
one, two, three,
Elden Ring.
So, I never played Bloodborne.
the rest of them. Yeah.
Not really. Honestly, I preferred um I
preferred three to Elden Ring.
Like the openw world version of it
basically forces you to use a wiki or
just have a completely terrible build
because like it's way easier to miss the
one item that you really need and will
be terrible without in something that
big.
I know the thing that's weird weird we
weird with that formula from a game
design perspective, right, is the idea
is that you're supposed to be able to go
around and like explore and be rewarded
for it. But instead, the way that those
games work is that you explore and 95%
of the time you're not rewarded for it
at all. And then 5% of the time you find
the one thing that you really, really
need. So if you miss that, you're just
screwed.
So yeah, I don't think the exploration
formula really worked as well in that
unless you're playing with summons, but
then are you really playing the game?
not grind though. So grind is when you
have to do the same thing over and over
no matter what.
In this case, you can beat them first
try. You're just bad.
I mean, you want to see grind open
Runescape. No matter what you do, you
have a minimum 500 hour mid game.
I don't know. I started um over my
vacation. I needed something to do in a
couple of the evenings or a few of the
evenings. So, I started playing WoW cuz
I'd never actually really played that
game for more than a week or two. And um
you know, I'm supposed to be the MMO AI
guy. So, it's kind of weird that I
haven't played the biggest one. and they
have completely
like ripped that away from the normal
MMO formula to the point that it's not
even really an MMO anymore. It's kind of
like a
I don't know, it's like a seasonal
party game with a bunch of mini games or
whatever.
It doesn't really have the same
progression element at all that uh
defines
that genre.
I played a little bit. I didn't really
play that many FPS games though.
Like I played a little bit. The vast
vast majority of all of my hours of
games are in MMOs.
Oh yeah, I remember. I think I had 300
hours on Emerald when I was very young.
Okay. So, we make it to here.
And now
like this, right?
Wonder log prop.
like this.
Okay. We got lock prop.
Nurmmo is still up. Yeah, all of their
old blog posts are
We are going to make this stupid thing
work.
At least I'm no longer just debugging
this blind. Now it's like pretty
consistent.
Okay,
this runs.
This actually runs
perfect.
I'm going to commit this. This is not
going to train at all until I fix about
a million things. Let it run.
Okay, committed. So,
lots of stuff to do from here. Um,
lots and lots of stuff to do from here.
First of all, I want to compile this
with
I want to compile this
without debug on.
So this number here is not going to be a
real number.
Is it not on there? Is that not it right
there?
I don't know.
3.7 mil. Okay, so something is wrong.
because
this should be way faster, right?
Well, how is this even working with?
Now I'm confused.
Yeah, I don't know what that is, man.
That's um
I wouldn't be surprised if they do it.
That company writes garbage.
What is happening?
Oh, train's 85%.
Huh?
have some other stuff running on this.
Check that next.
This one is always
one that freaking works
there.
How does it work?
puffer lib mu.
Uh, I believe so. Yeah. Though I'd
suggest just using MJX or something and
then using that bind. It'll be way
faster.
So, something weird happened because
this was way faster before.
I mean, he got his like his profile
wrong by a factor of 80. He didn't read
like the correct comparison.
So, kind of like distracted me for a
couple hours. And I thought that like
cuz the thing is if you actually got an
emulator to be 80x faster, um it would
be a huge deal for AI in general. Like
that would be a massive massive
contribution.
But like the thing is it's
you need frame skip to be accounted for
correctly in that number and he didn't
account for the frame skip
among other stuff.
Something weird happened because it got
slower. It was faster before
like and it's not even the section that
I played with at all.
Oh, I know what it is. I know what it
is.
I got it.
It was this
Yeah, rip that.
This is why traditional interviewing
path just sucks.
Like, it's not that hard realistically,
right? Like if you were to spend a fair
bit of time, you could get good at
those, even if it's incredibly
frustrating. But like getting good at
interviewing for jobs is not the same as
getting good at doing jobs. Which is why
the majority of software produced is
utter and complete [ __ ]
because they're evaluating people on a
criteria that has nothing to do with
their actual ability to do reasonably
good work,
even passable work.
Okay. It's good to see that this
actually has a huge impact. So, this is
now what's that? 9 mil.
I put the Ford back in.
Uh, this is not real numbers. Don't get
too excited yet.
I mean, I actually I'd be pretty
surprised if you could do just like, you
know, the same stuff and make it way
faster. I'd have to really look at it to
understand how much room there is for uh
performance improvement.
Yeah, exactly, Anish. That and that is
the problem with traditional
interviewing. So, like I chose to just
never do that. So, if you put elite code
easy in front of me, you'll make me look
like an idiot, but in fact, you're the
idiot, right? For asking me a dumb
question and expecting that to correlate
with anything. Um,
so I mean I like I run my own company.
It's now profitable.
It's growing. I'm doing cool stuff. I'm
contributing to science, but like I also
have credentials to fall back on and
lots of other stuff I can be doing,
right? So, it's difficult to recommend
to people that aren't in that position.
But yeah, I it's like I it's I can't
just say, "Hey, yeah, also just waste
the next three months of your life
prepping for interviews either, right? I
can't say that in good faith." It's kind
of just a dumb situation.
There are definitely places that you can
get hired at without having to do leak
code. Um, and they are probably places
that will have better people, but it's
not going to be as easy, right?
You have to actually be very good as
well.
I actually don't even know how this is
running.
Yeah. So that's uh about expected,
right?
So I mean this makes sense, right? This
is like this.
profiler is also breaking now.
It's annoying.
Yes. Okay. So, we're going to have to
figure this out before we can profile.
I suppose I can do it without threads,
right?
Maybe that'll work.
that's fine.
The thing with programming is like there
genuinely is not a set of stuff that you
should just be able to do um off the top
of your head. Like
the thing that you're going to be able
to do quickly without having to check
docs and stuff a whole bunch of times is
pretty much just going to be the exact
thing that you've been working on for
the last couple of weeks.
And other than that, like it will take
you slightly longer than instantly to
figure stuff out.
Okay, this runs
illegal memory address. Really?
Okay. So, how are we getting illegal
memory?
Look at the bite out of performance that
blocking launches cause.
Now it doesn't break.
So presumably it's a synchronization
error.
Um,
Okay.
So,
right,
that makes sense.
What have I missed? Um, we have like
some basic thing working. We have some
synchronization errors. It looks like
there's some speed up, but I don't think
we're seeing the full thing that we're
expecting yet.
It's probably just a really bad idea in
general to have this be shared.
So, let's just do torch
graphs.
Oh, this is way easier to do it this
way, isn't it?
Was way easier to do it this way. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. We're going to Okay. I was
stupid.
What games do I play?
Um,
well, when I'm working, not much of
anything. Um, I don't know. I downloaded
WoW over um over vacation.
It's okay.
It is nowhere near as addictive as uh
the other MMOs I used to play. I mean,
obviously I used to play a ton of MMOs,
right? That was like I did my PhD thesis
on AI for MMOs. Come on.
game game end to end. It's not fun yet,
but it's game. It works. Cool.
Did any of the emulator stuff end up
working?
off market, they're both going to keep
claiming victory back and forth every
few months for the next couple of years
while uh both being way short of what
they say they can do.
compiling it half inspire
state.
Well, I mean like the benchmarks, right?
Screen graphics.
Like even if you got it actually 10x
faster than um like not 80x faster, but
if you got it even 10x faster would be
still a pretty big deal.
10x faster would be
like a bit faster. I think quite a bit
faster than Atari.
So having seen the interview, what do
you think he's cooking? I don't know,
Jess. It seems like he's thinking about
very out there stuff and not very small
deviations or changes on top of a
standard LLM, which I think is a good
thing for the field.
Pretty annoying when I'm ruining it.
Yeah. Um
I don't know. I just ignore the people,
man. Like
I still don't have I still don't know
anyone who I know is good um
who is like given an actually reasonable
take on any of this stuff.
I don't know what the hell car Path is
on posting about like
I mean it's like the thing is it's so
easy to prove as well, right? like there
would be a bunch of legitimately good
LLM written libraries on the order of 1
to 5,000 lines of code um if these
models were as good as people say and
there just aren't
why do you need
32k amps
Why do you need that?
Demis is also on the compute is the way.
Well, I mean it is very likely that
compute is ultimately the way, but that
doesn't mean there's a difference
between needing to scale stuff longer
term and being able to make meaningful
contributions at smaller scale.
Wanted to see look like our new
vectorzation is just going to have the
threading B and C
with GPU buffering. It'll be way faster
and the target is like at 32KMS we
should be pushing 15 to 20 million steps
per second.
8K. We're going to hit 10 million.
Need a reason to test the gill list?
Yeah, I I don't know. I got bored of
waiting for that and I just figured
whatever.
There's really no reason to do um
like unless you're going to do like I
really don't think there's a good case
like you wouldn't be able to do the
thing that I'm doing here in Python with
the threading anyways. So, I really
don't see much point.
I will say that the the C vectorization
was a total [ __ ] to write.
That was not fun to make work.
But it does seem like it works now,
right? So, what I was going to do here,
um,
Yeah, we can totally just do it. It
doesn't have to be loaded in at all.
I believe with this
AI research is not automated at all.
I I like people just keep looking for
like shortcuts to be lazy and not bother
to do things. Like
People just being really really dumb
lately.
Okay, so now we have
we've got this graph captured
We no longer have to care about any of
this crap anymore
or block size. None of this matters.
Okay. Okay. And now we can phrase this.
And now we just have to allocate all
this stuff I think.
So let's just put this before create
environments.
six
batch
actions is just going to be
batch.
Boom.
So now we have this,
right? So now we have all of these uh
buffers
is just copy.
So we just dol
graph ops
Linux daily. Yeah, Linux is just what I
use. It has the side benefit of not
allowing me to install a few of the very
addicting games.
Oh, no. Wait, we don't need this.
So, it's already stored to this, right?
What is graph ops doing? So, Phil, what
I'm doing here is I'm allocating some
buffers that get reused um by the
network and the network is traced with
CUDA graphs. So, it goes into a single
CUDA call. You uh kill off a lot of the
launch overhead, right? And uh the only
requirement of this here is that I can't
just pass whatever uh whatever tensors I
want uh for the inputs and outputs. They
have to always be at the same spots. So
it looks a little weird, but that's what
it is. And once I have it cleaned up,
it's not really going to look any uh any
worse than the original was before I did
this.
Yeah, I have to do graphs.
As it turns out,
I was going to try to do torch compile
on its own and use that for graphs. It
turns out that is not exactly a good
idea.
Get rid of this.
Okay, that's a pretty simple function to
trace now, right?
You only need one graph.
Do make sure that you're timing it
correctly.
I'd be very surprised if you're 5x
faster than um
than other blasts.
That's something that should be
basically impossible to be 5x faster in
a in a fair test.
Oh, 5x slower. Oh, yeah. My bad. Well,
how much faster is the question.
We ever hired full-time interns of
puffer. We are taking one intern for the
summer.
Um Finn will be joining us.
Now in his case, right, I basically
couldn't say no considering that um he
was one of two people who contributed
the drone environment and that is the
best PR I have ever received.
So
full-time is hard though because the
thing with full-time is right like
Puffer is contract based. Um, so when I
if hiring full-time basically means that
I have to estimate the amount of
contracts that we're going to get
incoming
and I have to price in the risk of like
contracts being slow here or there and
stuff. Whereas when I hire people as
contractors for specific jobs, it's much
easier
cuz I just split you a chunk of the uh
you know, a chunk of the contract value.
Oh, okay. So, you got slightly faster 32
thread performance.
Interesting.
Yeah, that seems weird then because you
would not expect
if you're single threaded that slow, it
seems like you should not be able to do
that much better.
Oh yeah, something is totally wrong,
dude. There's no way that their
multi-threaded implementation is just
slower than their single threaded.
Timing threading stuff is really
obnoxious as well.
Come on.
Okay,
this works.
I can tell you I think benchmarks are
just a massive pain.
The graph can be registered to the
state.
Oh, wait. Um, graph
obs.
just uh I shouldn't need to call
anything else. This was working before.
I modified it slightly and I think I
somehow screwed up.
I'm trying to think if I'm like copying
the graph somewhere.
Get rid of this.
We don't need this.
Oh, wait. Are you supposed to Hang on.
Yeah, I see the problem.
Yeah, I see the problem. Um,
so this needs to be
like
honestly I should probably just do it in
line. Be easier. I see the problem.
like this.
No, it's it's dumb. Hang on. I'm just
tracing the wrong thing.
It's a very simple mistake. I'm just
Yeah, but then this one is part of it,
isn't it?
Oh, hang on. No,
I was almost correct before
No, wait. Isn't this fine?
Now I'm confused.
I thought I was accidentally copying the
data transfer.
Yeah. No. So, this is fine
that we do this in here.
Oh, okay. So, what the heck did I mess
up then?
Nothing.
That's bizarre.
Oh, that was weird. Oh, it's because
with launch blocking it doesn't show up,
right? So, we have to launch it without
still fine.
Interesting.
But we still get this illegal memory
address thing. But that was static error
is expected.
Uh we didn't necessarily expect to fix
that one.
Okay, but we can actually at the very
least
I got to go check when dinner is. I
might have to go.
Okay.
Solid, right?
Now
there's still some bugs
without vec
7 mil.
There's still some stuff we can do about
that.
Let me go check on uh dinner
real quick.
Hey.
Hey. What's the plan? What is the plan?
Dinner.
Thank you. When should I when should I
be done?
Yeah.
When should I come down? Six.
All right, I got like 30 minutes to
finish this. I'll be right back. Let me
use the restroom real quick.
man.
Okay.
What we have here?
Make sure that I compile this version.
Let's go figure out what it's doing
that's uh causing this
recommended practices. Train a model for
long
long-term planning game with nonlinear
progression.
Um, you can go look at the Pokemon blog
post.
If it's like really long like Pokemon
is, um,
then it's like not something that is
going to remotely work out of the box
yet. We have some stuff that's planned
for Puffer 5 to help with that.
But you'd be surprised that like a lot
of reasonably long games actually don't
require that much super long planning.
It's mostly a matter of what data you're
actually getting in training. Like if
it's a game like Pokemon where basically
all your data is from the start of the
game and all your data from the middle
of the game, like stuff changes quite a
bit.
The thing is if I do crude launch
blocking, it doesn't break.
Welcome.
Enjoy your new OS.
Okay.
So, um
something is right.
Can this be your longest frame? No.
It's going to be like eight hours and
change.
Yeah. So, it's not actually erroring
here.
Presumably, it is erroring because of
the forward pass somewhere.
okay, pretty much I think that there's
just some indexing screwiness.
I don't know what if I just
here
not do this copy either.
I'll just assume any of them can be
broken.
still a legal memory address.
That really doesn't make any sense to me
at all. Now,
okay.
I mean
nothing is happening in this loop. So,
oh, you know,
the only thing that's different here,
How's it possible that this breaks
though?
Okay. So, it is somehow tied to graph
creation, right?
And just to be sure,
if I do build this graph,
I'll make sure it's tied to the actual
creation of the graph.
Much faster do buffer. Yeah. So the
problem with that, right, is not much
faster because the environment is not
fast.
If you were to rewrite Dota like crazy
fast,
I mean, there would still be some
performance that we could get, I'm sure,
but
yeah. Okay. So capturing the graph
somehow breaks
profile.
So it's not anything we're doing. It's
the um
profile itself.
Okay. So, it's not something with
profiling
Um,
no. I've tried Sonnet.
I think I briefly tried what GPT5 or
whatever.
And the models are all just so freaking
bad.
No, I haven't bothered looking at Opus.
I guess I could get a sub just to play
with it a bit, but
yeah.
I mean, the response I got to that post
I made was mostly the people I know who
are like actually pretty good at what
they do telling me, "Yeah, that's like
none of the models are going to work for
you anyways." and then a bunch of not
cases like um
writing a bunch of stuff that makes no
sense.
The problem is it just doesn't happen
with launch blocking one.
Just just to be sure. I think this is
redundant, but we'll try this.
I mean, it's not even niche. It's just
complicated.
Like,
oh, your code is niche. That's so like
literally anything that's like
completely new, it'll just completely
fail.
It's not a del take at all. The del take
is like let's give over control to these
language models and just like build a
tower of dog [ __ ] that we're not
actually going to be able to like make
anything useful with.
I got to go for uh dinner in a few
minutes.
I may I might be back to do an evening
stream. We'll see.
That stuff just drives me nuts.
Yeah. So, I'm not even replaying the
graph. You see this? I'm literally I'm
not even replaying the graph at all.
Okay,
get rid of this.
I mean, I'm calling synchronize on this,
so how can this possibly
I don't understand how this can possibly
mess up
Look,
unless maybe hang on, maybe I miss maybe
the test was wrong. If I just do this
It's literally just making this thing
somehow screws up CUDA.
I don't know how that's possible.
Creating the graph screws up CUDA.
This will be the next thing to fix. I am
uh
I got to go get dinner, though. We made
some good progress at the very least.
So, um for folks who've tuned in,
thank you.
Uh if you're interested in my stuff
generally,
I stream a lot of dev. I'm going to be
streaming a lot more dev in the next
several weeks. Puffer.ai for all the
things. If you want to help me out for
absolutely free, just start the repo.
Feed the puff or a star. If you want to
get involved with development, join the
Discord. And other than that, you can
follow me on X for more reinforcement
learning content.
Thank